you know
good morning it's nine o'clock
and we're going to get started on the
joint economic briefing
thank the people that are here thus far
it gives us an opportunity to find out
where we stand relative to our revenues
so today will be primarily focused
by the agencies coming in to
talk about the revenues that they manage
as you can see by the agenda
the first speaker is going to be michael
kane
michael is the legislative budget
assistant for the state of new hampshire
michael joined the office
in 1999
and was appointed to the as the lba in
2015.
michael holds an mpa from south africa
university and a ba from merrimack
college
michael discussed the role of the lba in
assisting the ways and means and finance
committee michael
thank you representative major
good morning members of the committee my
name is michael kane i'm the legislative
budget assistant it's nice to see all of
you
so today i'll be very quick kind of a
high level where we are
just a little background the last budget
for the 22 and 23 biennium was passed on
june 17th of last year
when we developed the budget it's the
fiscal year the odd number fiscal year
so 21 and then projections for 22 and 23
and that's really where
ways and means
does
play a large role in developing the
budget for the next biennium
we're six months into an 18-month budget
so it's still very early as far as the
current biennium for fy 22 and 23.
what has occurred in december the
annual comprehensive financial report
which is the state this financial
snapshot of state was finalized and we
got a real sense of how did fy21
end
and so
just to tell you kind of what happened
is
ways and means committee our office will
work with the ways and means committee
to help develop throughout the session
to help develop revenue estimates you'll
have the agencies in as well but
multiple times during the session the
ways means committee will be looking at
the various revenue sources be it
business taxes meals and rooms
highway funds
just to get us to sense to the budget
writers in the finance committee on how
they can build their budget
so that's a very active process through
that budget process
then we have
we go to the finance committee who stay
within those
parameters provided by the ways means
committee that's historically what has
happened ways mean provides an estimate
to the finance committee who then
develops their budget based on that
estimate
there are then policy changes tax policy
changes are made during the budget
usually in coordination and consultation
or discussion with ways means to some of
those taxes which are then reflected on
a surplus statement that our office
presents so we have our base revenues
provided by the house ways and means
committee and then we have our final
estimated revenues
that are provided both ways and means
and the policy passed by the legislature
was a
good year as far as the general and
education trust fund is concerned um
left when we left on june 17th when the
the final budget was uh adopted
it was assumed that the rainy day fund
would have a balance of about 121.9
million dollars at the end of fiscal
year 21.
at the time the rainy day fund was
sitting at about 115 so it was about a
six million dollar deposit into the
rainy day fund at the end of 21.
within those two weeks as things have
changed
when the final kafir came out even
preliminary revenues revenues were
almost 90 million dollars up from where
the budget writers thought would be when
they had ended their budget discussions
on top of that the agency lapse was
almost over 70 million what the budget
writers had assumed in fiscal year 21
the fiscal year that they were actually
currently in
and then a couple other adjustments uh
with some accounting
the state actually ended up transferring
over almost
130 plus million dollars into the rainy
day fund so instead of
121.9 as estimated by
the budget writers at the time the rainy
day fund based on the most recent kaffir
that was released sits at
257.8 million dollars so significantly
above
where the budget writers and the
committee thought would be at the end of
june
so what i have before you here you'll
have a snapshot so snapshot is kind of
just a point in time look uh based on
what we know
the current budget year
is how that is trending
we know so we'll have two columns here
we have 22 we have the budget which is
shaded out so you can see what the
budget writers had assumed and i'll go
over those very quickly
budget writers had assumed 5.5 million
dollars would carry forward it from 21
to 22 and that is the education trust
fund because the education trust is
non-lapsing
revenue was estimated at about
272 billion 798 million dollars
budget appropriations after lapses at
about 2.687 billion current balance
about 111 with cumulative ending balance
of
117.4 million between both education and
general funds
there would then be at the end of 22 or
during 22 a transfer of 50 million into
the highway fund
to help shore up the highway fund due to
the decline in revenues
relative to the road toll
also so that would end the cumulative
ending balance
67.4 million dollars was what budget
writers had assumed
of that 13 million would be the general
fund which in the even number year
carries forward into 23 and 54.4 million
dollars into the education trust fund
no change in the
121.9 that's what the budget writers had
assumed so for 22 there's no transfer
into the rainy day fund from revenues or
expenditures
they do receive small amounts from any
settlement that the ag receives they
receive the first if it's over a million
dollars
they'll receive the first 10 percent so
there will be a couple hundred thousand
here and there usually in the
even-numbered year that will be
transferred into the rainy day fund
so that's where the budget
had
was projected at 22.
on row 2 under the preliminary you can
see the beginning balance coming forward
was not 5.5 it was 2.2 and that that's
basically indicating that the education
trust fund balance forward was about 3.3
million less than anticipated
estimated revenue
is the same on row five but the
year-to-date variance this is just
through december was 129 million dollars
over plan for both funds
and of that 129 million uh all but about
600 000 or so was general fund just
because a lot of in dra will be here
later talking about the business taxes
but
the business profits tax is performing
very well
the bet which has a larger impact on the
education trust fund based on the
statutory split
is not as high as the bpt and so what
happens is that the general fund is
benefiting so far
the largest beneficiary from the
additional revenue
and i would just caution that we are
only halfway this is only halfway
through the fiscal year march and april
are big months
over a quarter of your revenue is coming
in
in march and april so that's when a lot
of the returns are done the final tax
filings are due and lin commissioner
stepp can talk about this during her
presentation but there's still
there are still fluctuations that can
occur in march and april in addition
june is also a very big month for
business taxes and so even though you
are 129 million dollars above plan
through december i would just caution
that march april and june or very large
months for revenue collection and that's
really what weighs means we'll be
monitoring throughout the next couple of
months
how does january end
february is a small month but how does
march end in april and so that's what
the communities will be working on
as far as budget appropriations
billion 751.8 million dollars
we do that is what the budget writers
had assumed and that's all your house
bill one appropriations which are your
standard appropriations in the big 800
800 page document as well as house bill
2 individual appropriations which is the
trailer bill
so where finance comes in
and fiscal committee comes in there are
also unbudgeted appropriations that
budget writers are not
they do not project
during the budget process they're
typically in a normal year i say a
normal year hasn't been like that for a
while but
between eight to twelve million dollars
of
statutory appropriation things like
workers comp claims abandoned property
claims
legal settlements
judicial council funds additional funds
that come through the fiscal committee
litigation funds that the the
attorney general comes through fiscal
committee for additional
but we can see that just through
december on row 11
25.7 million dollars of unbudgeted
appropriations so yes the
revenues are doing well
but you also do have to continue and we
will continue to monitor the unbudgeted
appropriations so that's 25.7 million
dollars
now
of that amount
almost 10 million dollars of that is
education trust me related from two
two areas one is about eight million
dollars in the education freedom
accounts which is a direct draw on the
education trust fund and another two
point four million dollars is additional
inadequacy grants over budget based on
the actual student accounts
and then the remaining money is general
funds and about 10 million of that not
10 million about 5 million of that is
related to the department of justice who
has requested through fiscal two
requests for additional general funds
appropriations for litigation there is a
lot of litigation outstanding that the
attorney general is involved in when
they do need outside help they do come
back to fiscal committee for general
fund
authority typically budget had about 350
000 a year the fiscal committee is used
to the attorney general coming back in
usually in the 2 million range but we
know through december so far you're over
5 million dollars just from that one
that one department
uh estimated laps very what the lapse is
is basically your unexpended
appropriations so you know with an
18-month budget there these are their
projections revenues projection spending
of projections so lapses occur when if
positions are assumed to be filled for
the entire 18 months but are really only
filled for you know 12 out of those 18
months it will result in unexpended
appropriations and that will so collapse
to the general
fund so right now if we were to stop
today and this isn't even taking into
account the revenue i think revenue and
lindsay can talk about that uh revenue
through january is also above plan so
that 129 million dollar figure will
probably be up by the time the monthly
revenue focus comes in at the end of
january uh so the number could bump up
but just based on december what we
actually know
current year balance about 215.2 million
dollars
and the cumulative ending balance at
about 217.4
and that's basically your preliminary
your beginning balance plus your uh
current year balance
so compared to the budget on row 17
there's
roughly these are all rounded it just
worked out perfectly but it's about a
hundred million dollar difference
above
a positive above
where the budget writers thought the
ending balance would be in both those
funds
the transfer to the highway fund is the
same so on row 22 the 167.4
after the transfer to the highway fund
and 22 compared to the 67.4
where the finance committee and where
the ways and means committee will
continue to work is based on is on the
split between the education trust fund
and the general fund
because as you can see of the
100 million dollar difference if you
look on row 23 the general fund share of
that is almost
113 so
even though there's only 100 million
dollars the general fund is still
benefiting by about 113 million dollars
year-to-date what that means is that on
road 24 you are trending below in the
education trust fund instead of 54.4
million dollars which was the assumed
ending balance in 22 year-to-date you're
at about 40.6 so that's almost a 13
million dollar
almost 14 million dollar um
variance negative variance in the
education trust fund
rainy day fund again there will be a
couple thousand hundred thousand dollars
here and there but shouldn't change much
in the uh current year uh because it is
an even number year in any transfer in
the rainy day from the general fund
surplus will happen at the end of the
biennium in 23.
and then what i have on beginning on row
is your watch list and this is something
that both committees as well as our
office and the agencies will watch
obviously row 30 revenue versus plan
you're going to pay attention to what
happens in january february but
especially march and april
unbudgeted appropriations typically
you may see another 10 million dollars
come through either not necessarily
through fiscal committee but things like
your abandoned property claims that
happen near the end of the fiscal year
workers comp etcetera
it could be 10 plus or minus probably on
the lower side closer to 5 million
rose 32 and 33 are really your senate
financing your ways and means committee
um these are what you'll be these are
basically a priority to pay attention to
as you know as second committees you
monitor the policy bills that passes the
legislature
be it a revenue impact or an
appropriation impact
because since the budget was passed six
months ago you do still want to maintain
a balanced budget throughout
the biennium
on row 32 the legislative specials which
are all the the bills that have been
filed with appropriations or open
warrant authorities be it retirement
education trust fund um
100 million dollars for ydc
settlement based on those that
litigation
totals almost 400 million so about 390
million of bills are out there now not
all of these bills will pass there's
some you know can be some crossover
between
the bills
but that is something that the finance
committee continues to monitor as those
bills pass the policy committees what
are the bills that are on both sides
house and senate what are the bills that
are still alive what is the obligation
and then that's why our office is
involved with both the house and senate
finance committees to continuously
update them on the status of those
appropriations
and in row 33 legislative specialist of
revenue impact
revenue is very indeterminable but you
know just on what was provided on the
fiscal notes there are revenue bills
that could be 125 million plus
um
negative draw on revenues based on the
bills that are there and obviously ways
and means will be monitoring each bill
as it comes through your committee
as that goes through and we'll be
providing updates on what bills are
still alive as we go through the session
and again we are still only six months
into an 18 into a 24 month budget so we
still have a lot of time left
and then on row 34 is litigation this is
it's to be determined
if you look into the annual
comprehensive financial report there's
usually a litigation section and what
this does is point out those cases that
could have a material
potentially large impact on the state's
balance sheet
there are over 18 cases that were listed
this year in 21
large items i think the largest one
you've probably all been hearing about
and reading about is the sununu center
the youth development center
obviously 100 of that 390 million
appropriation is supposed is to put in
the fund to use a separate process to
fund that
but
that will take care of under 100 of
those cases and i think there are a few
hundred
potential
cases relative to the sununu center so
that's a
big exposure for the state obviously
going to happen over multiple years but
it's something that the legislature is
going to monitor the next uh several
months
next couple years
um and so total litigation you're you
know just you want to watch that you
also have the school funding lawsuit
that is currently i believe there's a
hearing coming up
we have to see what happens with that
because that will have an impact on the
education trust fund
it's an unknown but it could have a
significant impact on the education
trust fund
and then on the bottom of the list and
the watch list is statewide labs during
a typical year your statewide lapse
variance is the one that makes or breaks
the state other than revenues
but this year with the with the amount
of appropriations
in how well revenues are doing
then the laps at 64.8 million dollars
it's not a big it won't be a big
variance it's the first year for
biennium there's a lot of appropriations
that
carry forward into the next fiscal year
uh 64 is not a
on an ordinary crazy high figure uh
considering you've lapsed close to 200
million dollars
in 21. so
those are what
what we know of right now obviously this
will change we'll look at the monthly
revenue focus in january added to this
figure and update the committees both
finance and ways and means
throughout as those monthly revenue
focuses come on and then start pulling
off the bills that have not passed or
have been amended or any additional so
that's where i'll stop my presentation
kind of on 22 and i can answer any
questions
thank you mike
i do have a question
it has to do with the
rainy day fund at 257.8
million dollars
and you have a watch list on your bottom
you know i would like to see another
line
and
a line that says liability
because
that 200
when you look at that
257.8 million dollars wow we got 257.8
million dollars
we could
spend it on
anything
but
there's a couple things that
ought to be put on there
so that it balances that out
number one
last year when we discussed the ppp
whether we should tax it or not
that didn't pass until house bill 2
so the taxes were collected
there's 100 million dollars
that's not our money
that's part of this rainy day fund
another thing
is that credit carry over
is approaching 290 million dollars right
now
that's not our money either but that's
part of these figures
and if you took both of them we'd
probably be running a deficit
and all that so
is there any reason you couldn't put a
line in on
to
indicate the liabilities against the
rainy day fund
otherwise
people will look at that and say
we've got the money you might as well
spend it
we don't have
them questions
senator d'alessando
sure i can i can repeat the questions so
the question is
so senator d'alessandro's question was
on the positive side as far as
litigation is concerned the state just
received settlement from funds from
centene relative to uh
litigation
with the attorney general that had
settled so that's 20 million dollars so
senator dale sanders question was
10 of that based on current law 10
percent of that goes into the rainy day
fund
and will that just happen
that will happen prior to the close of
the fiscal year but depending if any
legislative changes happen prior to the
close
right now yes that 2 million would go in
and then just to follow up on
representative major yes
257.9 million dollars in the rainy day
fund but the credit carry over that's an
issue that the ways and means committee
has been watching very both watching
very closely for the last several years
it used to be in the tens of millions
it's now hundreds of millions of dollars
and what this is is for lack of a better
term overpayments by businesses as they
pay on estimates
so at any point in time
not all at once hopefully not all ones
is that this is money that is owed back
to the businesses and so they haven't
and the commissioner of dra can go over
this but they have an option when they
file their taxes to use some of these
credits so we'll monitor
at least the revenues but there are
these large outstanding issues
or large outstanding policy
changes that still haven't hit that
we'll have to monitor so i can add a
couple lines at the bottom with the
credit carrier amount which is an amount
reported in the um
the aquifer and then also the um the
amount for any
ppp or other potential revenue impacts
that could hit the numbers that you're
seeing on this snapshot
if you've got a question if you go to
the right
there's a mic at the table here
thank you mr chair
so on the watch list
um
is this i view this especially lines 32
and 33
i view this more of a watch list for
next fiscal year because
correct i mean it's the
fiscal year ends in june 30th
bills will not be signed more than
likely earlier probably in june
so there really won't be that much of an
impact in this fiscal year correct
correct so as far as the 390 million and
125 are your multiple year impacts
you're 22 which we're currently halfway
through you're 23 and any some do have a
24 impact but both 22 and 23 and as
representative abrami stated
as they go through the legislative
process there are some
most likely this will hit next fiscal
year really the watch list is just you
know kind of like the credit card
forward something for the legislature to
keep in mind that although the rainy day
fund is at a very healthy level there we
do have to monitor as we go into the
next fiscal year
further questions
don't see any further questions
be right on time
thank you thank you
our next speaker
is going to be
lindsey stepp who's commissioner of the
department of revenue administration
she's going to discuss
taxes collected by the dra
and how they operate
lindsey stepp
has been commissioner at the new
hampshire department of revenue
administration since december 2017
and previously served as assistant
commissioner
of the dra as well as a financial
analyst
lindsay began her career at ernest young
as an international tax transfer pricing
consultant
she received her master's of business
administration degree
from plymouth state university and her
bachelor science degree
in economics from trinity college in
haifa connecticut
commissioner
good morning everyone as chairman major
mentioned lindsey stepp commissioner new
hampshire department of revenue
administration with me is keen wong our
tax policy council he's going to drive
the presentation for me while i speak
moving to the next slide so as you may
know the department of revenue
administration administers 14 taxes for
the state of new hampshire which
represents just under 80 percent or 2.36
billion dollars of audited revenue
collected for the general and education
trust funds based on fiscal year 2021.
the dra we obviously have important
insights into the performance of the
state's most significant revenue sources
but we really lack the capacity to
perform more complex economic
predictions although you have a great
lineup
to talk about some of that both today
and next friday as well
just to talk a little bit of the outline
of the presentation we're going to talk
about year-to-date revenues we're going
to talk about factors that affect the
various tax types which can impact the
revenue collections and we're going to
look at the trend 10-year trend of
revenues compared to what plan looks
like today
if it's okay with representative major
what i'll do is i'll stop after each tax
type to take questions before we move on
to the next one
okay
moving on to meals and rentals tax so m
r as we refer to it is levied on
consumers for the purchase of taxable
meals
accommodation rentals and motor vehicle
rentals the tax rate was nine percent
through september 30th of 2021 and was
reduced to eight and a half percent for
october 1st 2021 forward
the tax is collected by the operator and
remitted to the dra monthly so when you
go out to eat you'll you will pay that
tax you will pay it to the restaurant
with your bill and then that restaurant
operator remits their total taxes that
they collect over the month to dra on
the 15th of the following month
school building aid debt service is a
monthly transfer that comes out of gross
m r tax revenue
this transfer was 14.6 million in fiscal
year 12 but has been gradually
decreasing to 8.3 million in 21 and is
currently at 8.1 million for fiscal year
22.
just to look at what audited tax revenue
has looked like
uh pre and now through covid so we saw a
5.5 increase in revenue from 18 to 19
fiscal year 18 to fiscal year 19.
then with covid
starting to impact we saw a 9.9 percent
decrease from 19 to 20
however we rebounded in 21 with a 6.1
percent increase over 20.
and year-to-date performance of m r has
been very strong fiscal year 2022 actual
revenue for the first six months so
that's through december is 29 percent
above plan and 3.9
above last year
i would note you might say why are we so
far ahead of plan and not as far ahead
of last year there is a new municipal
transfer that's occurring in fiscal year
22 that's occurring on a monthly basis
the total
and that didn't exist in 21 so that's
why those percentages look a little bit
off year-to-date transfer for the
municipal fund is at
51.9 million
so year-to-date gross m r revenue so
before the transfer
is 15.6 per hit
15.6
ahead or 3.1 percent ahead of the same
time period going back to fiscal 19
which would be before covid so if you
kind of remove the covid impacts and you
look pre-covered to today
we are 15.6 per percent ahead or 31.1
million ahead of the same time period
compared to 19. so m r is performing
very strongly
factors that affect m r tax revenue
obviously low unemployment rates people
are working they have money to spend
you can see here that
new hampshire's unemployment rate is
below
the national rate and has improved
this year versus last year 2.7 november
of this year versus 4.2 percent for
november of last year
also strong wages people have money to
spend federal stimulus money
has helped sustain m r
weather we like those sunny summers that
colorful fall foliage that snow that's
in the forecast for tomorrow that's all
good for m r you may have seen in the
news that this past summer was a record
summer tourism in fiscal year 21 with
4.4 million visitors which was up 21
from 2019
and with total spending of 2.1 billion
which was up 5 from 2019 so that's
certainly helps m r tax revenue
also just consumer behavior adapting to
covid
transitioning to outdoor dining expanded
takeout options we've also seen shifts
from people staying in hotels to
utilizing
rentals via rental agents you know
renting a house for a week with your
family as opposed to staying in a hotel
some stats on that fast food is up seven
percent compared to november of 2019
and but full-service restaurants have
remained flat so there's you can kind of
see that little bit of maybe impact of
covid where fast food was the best
option for people if they wanted to eat
out it seems like fast food remains
strong
also with respect to the rentals
rental agents are up 168 percent
compared to november of 2019 while
full-service hotels have remained flat
so again i think that is partially due
to what we saw with the expanded tourism
over the summer more people are coming
to new hampshire to stay and vacation
and it appears often utilizing that
rental agent service as opposed to
potentially staying in a service hotel
factors that may affect future m r tax
revenue so when we're looking to the
next few years
the continuing direct effects of cobit
19 on consumer behavior
did you lose a presentation
um
it's a separate i think it's a separate
presentation
i'll keep talking i think most of in the
audience have a picture have the copy in
front of you
infection and hospital rates you know
this could affect
m r revenue if people
don't venture out to eat out or stay in
hotels
um and then just general public
sentiment on social distancing if folks
don't feel comfortable eating in a full
service restaurant that may impact our
revenue
economic factors that affect consumer
behavior the end of federal stimulus
monies
pandemic unreal related employment
trends again unemployment is falling
that's good more people having money in
their pockets
strong wages drive consumer demand again
another positive thing for m r
you know a point to note though about a
concern staffing needs in the in the
hotel and hospitality and restaurant
industry you know if hotels or
restaurants don't have the staff to be
open then they can't sell the meals or
rent the rooms that are taxable
so the the constraints on the workforce
in the hospitality industry
is something that we want to watch and
see if it impacts m r revenue
supply chain constraints
inflation and rising fuel prices of
inflation continues and fuel prices
increase that could impact the number of
people that are able to spend the money
to travel say to new hampshire for their
summer vacation
and again as we talked about this the
shift that we've kind of seen in
behavior and spending from pre-pandemic
to you know where we are today you know
maybe it's a new normal
that fast food is is a larger driver
maybe the shift to rental rental agents
as opposed to full service hotels that
may continue in the future
so those are things that we'll be
watching we look at that breakdown on a
monthly basis and we'll continue to
track the trends there
the next slide is a nice 10-year picture
of m r tax revenue
so you will see the top
dashed line is fiscal 2021 plan revenue
the green line is 22 plan revenue which
will be net of that municipal transfer
of about 100 million dollars in total
and then the blue line is actual
so you will notice that 2021 performed
under plan even though it was a strong
year but obviously the plan for 21 was
developed in fiscal year 19 it was the
end of the biennium so we didn't know
that kovit was coming we didn't know the
impacts so even though it was a strong
performance it is showing below plan and
then again you'll see that large
difference between fiscal 21 actual and
plan but that is the result of the net
of the municipal transfer of about 100
million dollars
the next slide on page six just provides
a breakdown of the meals and rentals tax
by activity type
so as we as we've mentioned
the meals and rentals tax taxes meals
rooms and motor vehicle rentals so you
can see that the breakdown is fairly
consistent meals is our largest activity
type within the m r tax
you will see a slight shift in fiscal
year 21
to the meals where meals represented
82.1 percent
that is the highest over the period
that's shown here
and you'll see that that is really
coming kind of a shift out of room
rentals that are at 15.8 percent which
is one of the lowest years that we've
seen so meals have were the strong
performer in fiscal year 21.
that is the last slide on m r so i'm
happy to pause here and take any
questions
if you've got a if you have a question
just go to the mic
on slide on page five where it shows the
graph
now this is gross revenue
correct
question is that can you
provide
both graphs
because
when we work the issue
you want to know what the
total revenue is that's coming in
because we're not always aware we keep
forgetting what's being taken away from
it
and if we plan with this
we're not planning right
we can definitely provide the graph both
ways and when you start doing your
revenue estimates in the next
year
we will give you the gross amount so you
can apply growth rates to the gross
amount and then take out the various
transfers
good question
commissioner thank you for joining us
in the senate we're debating some bills
and the question arose is the rim system
which seems to be operating very well
and thank you for that smooth transition
is that capable of localizing the source
of mnr revenues by type sure
so that question has come up numerous
times over the years you know being can
we take m r revenue and attribute the
revenue to each and every town
and in some instances yes in other
instances no
so
if you are a standalone bakery that
operates on main street in concord and
you report under your address in concord
then we can attribute that revenue to
you
if you are a local chain of restaurants
and you operate say in concord
manchester
and nashua you are able to file a
consolidated return so you can file one
return for all three of those locations
and you might use your nashua address to
file that consolidated return
in order to
report the exact revenue for each and
every city in town we would then need
that operator
to
break out for us what was from nashua
what was manchester what was conquered
so it's an additional step that
operators would need to take
and we would need to essentially
disallow the consolidated filing
the other issue that
comes up is if it is a very small town
and there are
two or three m r operators within a town
say there's two restaurants
that would violate our confidentiality
provisions because if we were released
that number and you operated one of
those restaurants you now know exactly
what your competitors revenues are so we
we
have confidentiality provisions and
policies at the department where at the
municipal level we don't like to report
on anything less than 20. on a statewide
level it would be 10 but at a local
level we try to have 20 data points
before we report a number to preserve
confidentiality
i want to go back to the uh thank you mr
chair i want to go back to the reporting
of the revenues and the net part and
it's like three or four of these that
are out there in different areas of not
just m r i mean it'd be great if we had
a big powwow on this and come up with a
way because we just love
we'd love to just track pure revenues in
ways and means
and have that above the line and then
all the all the things that are going
into different funds fine
that that should be secondary because we
i know you're not responsible revenue
focus but we do look at revenue focus
which is not your department but
i think we need a powwow with everybody
to try to
come up with a way that we can all agree
is a good way to to present the revenues
every month for us to understand thank
you sure and you're correct there are
multiple transfers every month that
occur there's transfers school building
aid and municipal transfer now out of m
r in the real estate transfer
tax there's the l-chip transfer and a 5
million affordable housing fund transfer
that happens every fall so there's been
more and more of those over the last few
years so we can and we certainly as i
mentioned earlier would want to develop
a revenue plan on the gross amount
because it is still money being
collected and then take those transfers
out afterwards
first of all thank you thank you
commissioner there's a point though that
that people miss and that's the three
percent vigorage
that that
causes us a loss of revenue that remains
with the
with the vendor
now does that occur with the car rentals
also is it's across the board so
everybody gets to retain three percent
correct if they are filing timely and
filing electronically which is our
preferred method under statute for the
meals and rentals tax then the operator
for
to compensate them from collecting all
of your money when you go out to eat and
remitting it to the state on a monthly
basis they do keep three percent so so
if you were to do the breakdown that
some people are asking for
the breakdown would be reduced by the
three percent correct and people have to
recognize that that it's not they're
looking at one amount but it really it's
three percent less right and so again
that could be another area that we
forecast the gross amount before the
commission
um because that is still money that is
collected
it is just retained by the operator for
their uh to compensate them for their
their services
okay
on to the real estate transfer tax so
the real estate transfer tax is on the
transfer sale and granting a real
property at a rate of 1.50 per 100 of
the price or consideration that is
typically split
75 cents to the purchaser and 75 cents
to the seller rent revenue has increased
in recent years we saw a 2.5 percent
increase from 18 to 19
a 3.7 percent increase from 19 to 20
and then a 32.4 increase from 20 to 21
primarily driven by the effects of
the housing market values in the housing
market increasing more people moving to
rural areas like here in new hampshire
they've seen the light they know that
this is a wonderful place to live
for fiscal 22 actual revenues for the
first six months of the year are 8.1
percent of prior year and
18.9
of last year
factors that affect
revenue low interest rates obviously
help with the sales of
housing
that amount or that interest rate was at
3.07 percent for october of 21.
obviously that might be ticking up in
the next few months as interest rates
increase due to inflation
strong demand coupled by decreasing
inventory levels
shift as i mentioned from urban to more
rural areas
and also property values so property
total equalized value for new hampshire
on
for april of 2021 was
193.5 billion dollars
and that's versus
eight
184.9 billion in april of 2020.
looking back we've seen approximately a
five percent increase in total equalized
value
over the past three years so the value
of property in new hampshire is
increasing
factors that may affect future rent
revenue the current housing market trend
obviously there's strong demand for
homes home prices continue to remain
strong but there is that lack of
inventory so really rhett revenue is the
balance between
sales volume and price if sales go down
if the volume goes down but the price
goes up your revenue can sustain
alternatively if the price falls but the
volume goes up your revenue can sustain
and we'll see that on the next slide
where we're going to see rent revenue
fall is with the decreased inventory and
if those housing prices start falling
then that will will see the negative
impact
in terms of the economy again low
unemployment rate and strong wages wages
are helpful for rent people have buying
power
inflation on the rise and a rise in
consumer prices and energy prices could
tamper on the hot real estate market
that we've been seeing
there's been some changes in behavior
due to cobid virtual home sales were not
really a thing pre-covered but
i think we may have all heard stories of
people buying houses cite unseen based
on a virtual home tour so that
definitely helped us
sustain
sales and transactions during the
pandemic
folks have been doing a lot of home
improvements increasing their home value
and then some folks have been putting
their homes on the market increasing
their rent revenue
and then obviously the ability to work
from home being able to move away from
those urban centers live in a more rural
state like new hampshire
and purchase and live purchase a home
and live here
things that we're looking at in terms of
the future as i mentioned increasing in
interest rates due to inflation
there's still that strong buyer demand
but if that does start to decrease
that could impact rhett and also the
impact as we've mentioned on inventory
it is very low
inventory in december of 2021 decreased
year over year by 34.4 percent for
single family homes and 41 percent for
townhouse or condo properties so that's
just a one-year decrease so december of
last year to december of this year
for to look at the specific
year-over-year change for rhett so for
november of 21 november of this calendar
year new property listings pending sales
and monthly supply of inventory for a
single family homes and condos decreased
from a year ago
but for november 21 the median sales
price for single-family homes and condos
increased compared to 2020. so the
average sale price for a single-family
home in new hampshire was 401 thousand
dollars in november of 21 and the
average sale for a condo in new
hampshire in november of 21 was 310 000.
so in the chart there you can see the
sales price year over year has gone up
by 13.6 percent
and the inventory has gone down by 30.8
percent for single-family homes
so again if those things move in
opposite directions we can sustain the
revenue but if they start to trend in
the same direction that's where when
we'll start to see a decrease in red
increasing construction and material
costs and supply chain issues are
causing a four to twelve month backlog
of certain materials
per the associated general contractors
of america that is going to impact your
inventory it's difficult to get the
supply supplies necessary to build new
homes to put them on the market
december just last month was the lowest
month in the last year on the
affordability index for single family
homes so single family homes had an
affordability index of 101 in december
of 21 which means the median household
household income was 101 percent of what
was necessary to qualify for a median
price home under the prevailing interest
rates
in one hand that's a good thing it's
more than a hundred percent so people
should qualify but by contrast
the state's residential affordability
index has been as high as 220
in february of 2012 and there was a
seven year period between 2009 and 2016
during which the index never dropped
below 150.
so that's where you're you know hearing
people say i just can't afford
to buy a new home i can't afford to move
that affordability index has come way
down compared to prior years
looking at the red 10-year revenue trend
again that green line is 22 plan
the red dash line is 21 plan and then
the blue solid line is the trend we've
seen over the last 10 years
similar to m r that 21 plant amount
which looks very low compared to actuals
for 21 that plan was developed in in
fiscal 19 so it was before we started to
see this real
boom in the housing market
you will note
that plan for 22 that green line is less
than
um
fiscal 21
actuals we did anticipate
that this housing market was gonna start
to cool off
that hasn't happened yet
so that's why you will hear that we are
above plan and we are above prior year
we
just assumed at some point this was
going to have to slow down i think it
does still have to slow down it just
hasn't happened yet
so we'll see what the last
six months of the fiscal year bring
and with that i will pause for questions
if there are any on the real estate
transfer tax
okay
onward to the tobacco tax so tobacco tax
is levied on each pack of cigarettes at
a rate of dollar 78 per pack of 20
cigarettes and 2.23 cents per pack of 25
cigarettes
tobacco tax is also levied on other
tobacco products so non-cigarettes but
still tobacco at a rate of
65.03 percent of the wholesale sales
price
so the tobacco tax is a makeup of the
stamp revenue and the other tobacco
product revenue
included in other tobacco products is
also e-cigarettes
given the the content or the fact that
e-cigarettes contain nicotine
so audited tobacco tax revenue over the
last three years we saw a 4.3 percent
decrease
from 18 to 19
a 5.7 increase from 19 to 20
18.1 percent increase from 20 to 21.
fiscal year to date actual through
december were 1.9 below plan and 4.8
percent below prior year
really the composition of the tobacco
tax is changing
otp has grown and currently makes up
about 10 percent of the tobacco tax
compared to looking at a decade ago in
2012 it was only 3.4 percent of the
revenue
factors that contribute to the tobacco
tax cross-border elasticity so
massachusetts implemented a ban on
methylated and all-flavored tobacco
products in effect on june 1 of 2020.
that has and we'll see this in later
slides has really driven the tobacco tax
revenue here in new hampshire if you
talk to convenience stores or any
sellers of cigarettes near the border
they were having a hard time keeping
mentholated products in stock because
they couldn't be sold in massachusetts
so people from massachusetts were coming
to new hampshire to purchase those
products
same with any mentholated or flavored
other tobacco product as well
also factors contributing to the tobacco
tax revenue is the implementation and
now full fiscal year results of taxation
of e-cigarettes
going to the next slide so just to go
over the e-cigarette tax that went into
effect on january 1 2020 and it's levied
on closed systems and open systems so a
closed system is kind of a one-piece you
buy the e-cigarette
liquid is already contained within the
cartridge
open system would be an e-cigarette
where you can swap out the liquid
and it's separate from the actual
electronic cigarette
they're taxed differently so closed
systems are taxed at 30 cents per
milliliter on the volume of the liquid
and then open systems are taxed at eight
percent of the wholesale sales price on
the container of liquid
so you'll see the e-cigarette tax fiscal
year 21 was a full fiscal year of the
tax
generated just over five million dollars
of the tobacco tax and year-to-date we
are at 3.8 million dollars so it is
proving to be
a fairly significant
portion of tobacco tax revenue
looking at the tobacco tax 10-year trend
you'll see the tobacco taxes kind of
fluctuated over the years from 2016 to
2019 we had seen a pretty consistent
downward trend approximately three
percent a year
however with the impact of covid and the
ban of mentholated products and flavored
products in massachusetts you'll see the
pretty significant increase from 19 to
20 and 20 to 21.
so
that will i think remain at this similar
level
given the ban in massachusetts and just
the driving of consumers here to new
hampshire
you can see on the next slide this is
just tobacco tax stamp revenue so this
is just revenue that's on those packages
of cigarettes
again you'll see that increase from 19
to 20 to 21
in particular due to
people purchasing methylated cigarettes
here in new hampshire where they can't
purchase them in massachusetts
and then on the next slide this shows
the increase that we've seen in other
tobacco products again i mentioned that
it's increased substantially over the
past few years
the portion shown in orange is what we
the tax revenue that's attributable
attributable just to e-cigarettes so you
can see how that makes up the total for
other tobacco tax product revenue
and with that i'll pause for any tobacco
tax questions
i know i asked you thank you mr chair i
know i see this lindsay
during the budget process
our only concern my only concern is that
massachusetts will figure out that maybe
we made a mistake and that will repeat
they would
peel
the methyl thing so have you been bird
dogging that a bit maybe any other
idea where that is maybe i have not
heard
any desire by massachusetts
to reverse that ban
i know that obviously in new hampshire
we have seen
a positive impact on
revenue due to that ban and i've also
been speaking to my counterparts in
rhode island who have seen a similar
increase as well but we have not heard
anything about massachusetts reversing
that ban
okay
on to interest and dividends tax
ind is currently assessed at a rate of 5
on interest and dividend income of
individuals partnerships and fiduciaries
audited ind revenue over the last three
years we saw an 8.4
increase from eighteen to nineteen a
nine point six percent increase from
nineteen to twenty and then a four
percent decrease from twenty to twenty
one
actual revenue for the first six months
so through december of the current
fiscal year is 21.1 percent above plan
and 17.3 percent below prior year
again you'll note that distinction there
we're above plan yet we're below prior
year
um the reason why we're below prior
years we saw a significant amount of
interest and dividends tax revenue in
july of fiscal year 21 that was due to
the federal due date change in the
individual income tax we did not follow
that same due date change in new
hampshire but many individuals
submitted per the federal due date so we
saw the money show up in july that would
have actually been due
in june we extended our due date to june
feds went till july a lot of people
followed the federal deadline so that's
why it's looking like we're very low
compared to prior year it's really just
a timing issue
ind tax rates will reduce by one percent
each year for the taxable periods ending
december 31st 2023 forward and the ind
tax will be fully repealed for taxable
periods beginning after december 31st
that is per house bill 2 of the last
session
factors that can affect ind obviously
economy and stock market performance
changing makeup of how ind is paid
you'll see on a later slide we've seen
really a shift
over the past 10 years or so away from
interest and more towards dividends
making up our distributions making up a
larger portion of the interest and
dividends tax revenue
past federal tax reform
there's been federal tax changes over
the years some might remember the fiscal
cliff a few years back that caused some
behavioral changes in some businesses
that caused them to accelerate dividends
into
december of a year rather than january
so we do kind of
watch what's happening federally because
that can kind of shift revenues around
for us
with respect to ind
money in the bank determines how much
interest you earn on it and obviously
the interest rates impact how much
interest as well
ind tax revenue 10-year trend you will
see that we are planning an increase in
fiscal year 22 over 21.
you will see though from 2016
up until 2020 there was a fairly
consistent increase year-over-year in
ind
it's approximately
7 percent increase
since 2016 that we've seen and that kind
of blip from 20 and 21
is for audited revenue while the money
was collected in july
we did move it back for auditing
purposes to fiscal year 20. so that's
why you see that weird kind of bump
there at the end
on slide 18
as i mentioned interest and dividends
tax components a 10-year trend
if you look at the top um
line at the chart at the bottom
distributions you'll see in tax year 11
distributions made up 21.2 percent of
the interest and dividends tax revenue
in 2020 that was 41.5
so that's really an indication of a
strong economy
and businesses issuing distributions
again as i mentioned going down to
interest interest in tax year 11 was at
33.3 percent went to a high of 41.2 in
tax year 13 higher interest rates and
then as interest rates have fallen over
the past few years we're down to 12.2
percent of the ind tax being made up
by interest so i think it's just
important here to know you hear interest
and dividends and my mind admittedly
goes to interest but the various
components
do kind of move in opposite directions
at times and so that can kind of help
sustain the revenue
that is all i had on ind happy to answer
any questions
no all right onward utility property tax
upt is taxed on the value of utility
property at a rate of six dollars and
sixty cents per one thousand dollars of
value as determined by the dra
as of each april first
upt revenue over the past few years we
saw a 12.5 percent decrease in 19 over
9.6 increase in 20 over 19. 11.8 percent
decrease in 21 over 20.
year-to-date through december we're
about 5.5 below plan and 13.4 percent
below unaudited revenue
tax year 2021 assessments totaled 42.8
million in tax so roughly the upt is
between 40 and 45 million dollars a year
but the total value of utility property
that generates that 42.8 million is 6.5
billion dollars
in
property value
factors that can impact upt development
of new renewable energy facilities
that's more taxable property
valuation of the property obviously is
directly tied to the tax so higher value
higher tax
energy pricing supply and demand that
impacts the profits of the utilities and
therefore impacts their property value
so
those can factor into their property
values and contribute to the tax
it's a short section on upt if there are
no questions i'll move on to
communication services tax
cst is a tax of seven percent on all
two-way communications
in 2012 there was an exclusion of
charges for internet access which
decreased cst revenue significantly
so from 2009 to 2012 cst revenue was
between 76.5 million and 81 million
after the exclusion 2013 to 2017 cst
revenue has been between 47.1 million
and 59.3 million
revenue has been fairly consistent over
the last few years between 39.8 million
and 43.4
fiscal year to date we're about 18
percent below plan and 16 percent below
unaudited revenue
prior year on audited revenue that's
primarily due to some taxpayers using up
some credits that they had on account
factors that can affect cst
decrease in landlines
modern pricing and purchasing trends for
wireless communications and a move to
voip and video conferencing
again fairly small tax but wanted to
make sure that you had the full picture
with that i'll move on to business taxes
i saved that for the end
oh sure
do we capture all the different types of
virtual communications
to a communication tax
so yes the department's position is that
the majority of video conferencing is
two-way communication
under the communication services tax and
so we've been working with the large
providers of those services to ensure
that they are reporting and remitting
appropriately
okay business taxes
as you know business taxes has made up
the business made up of the business
enterprise tax and the business profits
tax
the bet is assessed on the sum of all
compensation paid or accrued interest
paid or accrued and dividends paid by
the business
bbt is assessed on the income from the
conduct of business activity within the
state
currently the bpt conforms to the united
states internal revenue code of 1986
that was in effect on december 31st of
with adjustments and that is applicable
for taxable periods beginning on or
after january 1 of 2020.
factors that can affect business taxes
obviously the economy federal tax reform
and stimulus programs mergers and
acquisitions credits or exemptions and
statutory changes and i'll touch on some
of each of those in the next few slides
business taxes
so highlights of some recent statutory
changes we've made quite a few
over the past couple years
so market-based sourcing apportionment
for the sourcing or apportionment of
services began for taxable periods
ending on or after december 31st of 2021
and so we will start to see the impact
of that on returns that will be filed
beginning in march and april of this
year
single sales factor apportionment will
begin for taxable periods ending on or
after december 31st of 2022 so that's
where we move from our current three
factor apportionment
of payroll property and sales to just
apportioning based on a businesses sales
so that's for the calendar year that
we're currently in
there's also an increase to gross
business income bpt filing threshold
from 50 000 to 92 000 for taxable
periods ending on or after december 31st
of 2022
likely to have a small
revenue impact but will basically
decrease the number of returns that we
will receive and process so it's
favorable to the businesses if they're
are submitting um if they have a filing
threshold but they're not paying any tax
they won't need to
make those submissions anymore
and we also increased the bet filing
threshold
for gross business receipts to 220 000
or 250 000 from 220 and the enterprise
value
threshold went from 110 000 to 250 000
as representative major mentioned
earlier
the forgiven paycheck protection program
loans will be excluded from bpt
that fiscal impact is approximately 100
million dollars based on dra estimates
and then we did see a reduction in or
we'll see a reduction in bpt rates from
7.7 to 7.6 percent and bet rates 0.6 to
0.55 for taxable periods ending on or
after december 31st of 2022.
so a lot of these legislation
legislative changes or statutory changes
are in effect for the current calendar
year that we're in
and we'll start to see the effects of
that through businesses estimate
payments that we receive
in april june september and december and
then on return filings that we receive
next year
another change that i wanted to mention
based on representative major's comments
about the credit carryover limits
there will be
limits imposed currently there's no
limit on a business's credit carryover
they can carry they can file estimates
with us they can pay a bunch of money
and then they can leave that money on
account to carry it forward
there will be limits imposed beginning
for taxable periods ending 1231 of 22
and that will start at 500 percent of
their taxable liability so they cannot
have a cco that's in excess of 500 of
their current year liability anything in
excess will need to be refunded
that cap then goes to 250
for 1231 of 2025 and down to a hundred
percent of their taxable liability in
1231 2027. so that almost 300 297
million in credit carryover that
representative major mentioned earlier
that will start to decrease as these
caps are imposed
just looking at business tax revenue for
2012 to 2021
[Music]
really the point of this slide is just
to show you
business tax revenue can be sort of
volatile
recent volatility really has been
magnified by covid and federal due date
changes but here you can see the
year-over-year change dollar amount and
percent
in revenue and then we also highlighted
the change in dollar and percent of the
plan revenue so even even plan has kind
of fluctuated over the past few years
fiscal year 2022 actual revenue for the
first six months again through december
is 16.9 percent ahead of plan and 27.9
ahead of prior year so fiscal year 2022
is off to a strong start as
mr kane mentioned earlier these are
numbers through
december but january revenue remains
very strong as well
factors that impact business tax revenue
first looking at kind of towards the
past
um
factors that contributed to business tax
revenues overall business gains were
experienced in the technology medical
retail and financial sectors over the
past few years
i think particularly
these are some industries that did well
during covet right retail
sales have been very high
obviously the medical industry
and technology have
performed very well during the pandemic
looking to the future
direct effects of covid19
you know can businesses sustain
infection rates at the workplaces can
they sustain a remote model going
forward it has proved very successful
for a lot of businesses so hopefully
that is not a negative impact
on the economy and on business taxes
as i mentioned previously with mnr
workforce shortage is something that i
think we need to kind of keep our eye on
in terms of whether that could have a
negative effect on business taxes
businesses don't have the workers to
perform the work they can't generate the
profit
that ultimately would be taxed under the
bpt so that's something to keep an eye
on
we mentioned the statutory changes on a
prior slide
also just general trends in the economy
that i think we've all heard about the
supply chain constraints are certainly
impacting businesses and their ability
to perform their functions and generate
profits
inflation rates
and the ending of stimulus programs
could impact consumer spending again
affecting profits
and then the low unemployment rate
is great when you have all the workers
that you need but can be difficult when
you're trying to hire
future outlook potential
interest rate increase that i think
we've all heard about and then you know
we're also looking globally at the
geopolitical instability that is
existing right now and what
if any effect that might have here in
new hampshire
you may have seen in the news that
nationally gdp grew at 6.9 percent
in 2021
predictions had been at 5.5 percent so
6.9 percent gdp growth exceeded
expectations it was the strongest growth
of gdp for a full year since 1984.
um
but you know as we're mentioning in this
slide you know there's definitely
headwinds to that growth and whether or
not that can be sustained
is probably unlikely so something we're
watching as well revenues for us don't
typically track
very consistently towards gdp you know
gdp is just kind of one of the factors
that we factor in but it's not to say
that if gdp increases by 6.9 then we're
going to see the same increase in
business taxes there's not that direct
relationship but it is one of the things
that we
continue to keep an eye on
in terms of a 10-year trend
you see a little bit of that volatility
you will see that the plan the fiscal
2022 plan in the green dashed line
is less than
fiscal year 2021
actual
and that's primarily due to the fact
that june of last year
was a very strong revenue month we had
already completed our revenue estimating
and we thought we were we had kind of
hit the nail on the head but we had
actually underestimated
um so
june revenue came in about 20 million
dollars higher than we anticipated so
that's why you see that that we actually
ended last year higher than plan for
this year
although i think we all assumed a
year-over-year growth
this is a historic look at the makeup of
business taxes so our primary business
taxes come into the dra in a variety of
ways they come in through tax notices
we find either an audit issue or we find
that you maybe
submitted a return without a payment we
send you a tax notice
um returns those are the final big
documents at the end of of the year that
businesses file so we receive money
through returns
extensions taxpayers are able to
pay their full liability by the due date
which would be in march or april
depending on the entity type and then
they get an automatic seven month
extension to file the paper returns so
as long as you've paid the money by the
due date we give you another seven
months to complete that nice thick
filing that you need to send to us so we
receive a fair amount of revenue through
extensions where taxpayers are making
that payment in order to have the
additional time to file the return
but you'll notice the largest makeup of
the revenue is in the form of estimates
so taxpayers file four quarterly
estimates in april june september and
december
the the issue with estimates it's a it's
a large portion of the revenue that we
receive and there's not a lot of
information on the estimate it's a nice
simple form with your name your address
your taxpayer identification number and
the amount that you want to send us
so we don't have details from estimates
about why that estimate might be more or
less than the prior year estimate for
the same taxpayer
which is why we need to ultimately wait
for those returns to come in before we
can really dissect what's going on with
revenues for any given year
the next slide is a similar breakdown
just based on entity type
so
we have fiduciaries proprietorships
partnerships and as you can see
corporations are our largest taxpayer
they are consistently the majority of
our revenue
for anyone that has spent some time
looking at the dras annual report this
might look familiar to you based on the
triangles that we produce and the fact
that the vast majority of our revenue
comes in
from multinational corporations
the next slide just shows a breakdown
over the past
decade or so of the business enterprise
tax versus the business profits tax
you'll see that they tend to track
consistently so if one goes up the other
one goes up but you'll note in 21
from 20 to 21 the slope of those lines
are different
so we've seen a greater shift towards
the bpt
as opposed to the bet
and i think that largely has to do with
the trends that we mentioned earlier in
the economy of those industries that
have performed very well you know retail
technology medical there's been a lot of
large profits
that have been apportioned here to new
hampshire um and that is more necessary
we haven't seen that same growth in our
business enterprise tax base so greater
growth in profits compared to the base
of wages interest and dividends of the
bet
i will pause there for business tax
questions
i've got a question it pertains to
slide 25 and also 28.
potentially
and then
i'm sorry and then
what
are you able to extract
from this
the effect of the various stimuluses
that have gone on
because the stimulus is going to go away
when it goes away
where are we going to end up at is it
going to be ending up below the red line
so
the first question is that that growth
you see from 20 to 21
could
ppp be contributing to that growth so
as mr kane mentioned earlier you'll
remember that
new hampshire given our conformity to
the internal revenue code
ppp loans were taxable to forgiven ppp
loans were taxable here in new hampshire
although they were tax exempt federally
until around june
when the legislation passed to make them
tax exempt so there is the potential
that
taxpayers paid following the new
hampshire
code as if those forgiven amounts were
taxable
and then they were deemed not to be
taxable so we may be in a refund
situation
i think what we're learning
as we continue to dissect the numbers is
that
some some taxpayers did pay based on
their forgiven ppp and will be in either
in a refund or credit situation
others because of the delay in the
forgiveness official forgiveness of the
loans taxpayers waited to see
whether or not the loan would be
forgiven and so if they waited they it
was still alone which was not taxable at
the time that they filed
so i don't think we received the full
hundred million and i don't think we'll
see the full 100 million be a reef under
credit it's somewhere in between
and we just don't know exactly
where in between because we could not
tie out the data from the small business
administration directly to our data in
new hampshire
the
second question
was related to stimulus and whether or
not we will see
a potential decline in revenues as the
stimulus program child tax credit
programs come to an end
i think there's potential for that i
mean certainly the stimulus
gave
individuals money to spend we mentioned
earlier how well the retail sector or
the retail industry did during the past
few years and i think that's largely due
to the fact that people had money in
their pocket to spend
so that that could be something
that we see
impact revenues going forward however we
don't have a direct connection
you know i can't say that this you know
thousand dollars of stimulus money that
this person received directly um made a
direct connection to business taxes so
it'll really just have to be something
that we watch and certainly if the
economy continues to grow
then the stimulus programs will have
propelled the economy
and if it continues to grow then
hopefully
so will our revenues but if the economy
starts to taper off or decline then
certainly the lack of stimulus there
could become more apparent with respect
to revenues
thank you mr chair lindsay again um
let's go back to market-based sourcing
you know when we were debating this
couple years ago in the house ways and
means
yeah when we were debating uh
market-based sourcing several years ago
and house ways and means anyway
we concluded that
it was very important that the dra be
able to identify
service companies in other states that
are going to be providing services to
new hampshire
and i i just want to i'm just curious to
how we're doing at that sure thank you
so
so market-based sourcing went into
effect
for taxable periods ending december 31st
of 2021 so the calendar year that just
ended
it is a focus of our audit division but
i will say
one of the reasons why market-based
sourcing kind of came to light
was that
new hampshire was still using a cost of
performance method for the apportionment
of services so we looked to where the
service was being performed
as opposed to market-based sourcing
which looks at where the service was
received
cost of performance was inconsistent
with some of the other new england
states maine and massachusetts in
particular they had already moved to
market-based sourcing so there were some
taxpayers that got kind of caught up
where they were following
market-based sourcing if they operated
in let's say they operated in maine new
hampshire massachusetts well two of
those three states were market-based
sourcing
and a few taxpayers got caught up with
not shifting to cost of performance when
they filed here in new hampshire
now that we're consistent
in all three states and other states in
new england are market-based sourcing
it is more
it's easier for taxpayers to comply
because it's consistency and uniformity
across the states so it's hard when you
make the move in the first instance if
you're the first state to move to
market-based sourcing you really have to
go out there and make sure that
taxpayers are following the correct
apportionment but when you're towards
the later end like new hampshire it's
really just creating consistency and
uniformity amongst the states so it's a
lighter lift on the part of the
department to proactively find those
businesses but we certainly are doing
that
much more comfortable yeah
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
uh in looking at the most recent revenue
estimates from lba we know i noticed
that business profits is tracking well
above plan business enterprise is
tracking significantly below
is that a normal
pattern for this time of year based on
filings and so forth or is that
something we need to be concerned about
no i would say that it
it's not something to be overly
concerned about
given our new revenue information
management system or rims we're better
able to
allocate bet and bpt to the appropriate
buckets
so historically what would happen is
most revenue would come into the
department and would be kind of marked
as bpt and at the end of each month
we would split that revenue based on the
historic split right a bet and bpt
now with rims
we have a
better way of doing that so let's say an
estimate payment comes in and there's
just one dollar amount on it and it's a
million dollars
we split that million dollars based on
the historic percent but when the return
comes in
let's say that million dollars was
mostly bpt because it's a large
multinational corporation they don't
have much of an enterprise value base
here in new hampshire will shift that
back
to the actual amount per the return and
so what that has caused in filings that
we've received up till this point in the
fiscal year is we've seen more
businesses as you could see where that
the slope of those lines were different
we've seen that there's really been a
shift more towards bpt than bet than
we've seen in the past i think once
returns start to come in in march and
april that will will taper off a little
bit and and bet and bpt will come a
little bit closer to plan so i think it
is just a timing issue but it's
partially due to kind of a change in how
we're trying to allocate the revenue to
make it more accurate
okay i'll just close with a couple
slides that i included to just kind of
give you um a picture of where we are
today
so this slide historical revenue trends
just kind of puts everything on one page
uh really what you will see here
is that
while at the beginning of the pandemic i
never would have guessed this but for
our tax types due to covet or during the
the course of the pandemic over the past
almost two years our tax types have
either remained flat or have increased
obviously at the start of all of this i
was estimating significant decreases in
our revenues and that just didn't come
to fruition so for the the tax types
shown here you can see it's either been
flat over the course of the pandemic or
they've increased
the next slide highlights what mr kane
was saying earlier you'll see for fiscal
year 22 we've included actual revenues
through december through the first six
months of the year
we've included
the first six months of plan and then
how they performed versus plan so you'll
see business taxes we're up 16.9 percent
in the head over plan through december m
r is up 30 percent
um
ind up 21
but i'd
shift your attention to the last column
where it shows what the last six months
of plan are compared to total plan
first let's look at ind
ind in the second six months we're going
to bring in 75 76 percent of had a
percent of plan
so for ind i would just say we've only
got even though we're halfway through
the year only 25 percent of the revenue
has come in
so i wouldn't put too much weight on our
variants to plan at this point because
the vast majority of our revenue is
still to come
you'll also see generally the rest of
the taxes are about 50 percent
in the first half of the year 50 in the
second half of the year
but m r and rhett
you'll see those taxes are closer to 40
percent and that's due to a slowing that
we typically see in those taxes during
the winter months
um
there it does not appear to be a slowing
in ret for january uh revenues based on
december transactions but that may still
come again with m r we do tend to see m
r kind of taper off either in the winter
months or during mud season
when tourism isn't as strong
so just just something to note that the
plan is not necessarily evenly split
between the first and second half of the
year
and then lastly just to be thorough
there are a few taxes that dra
administers that i didn't cover today
but want it to be thorough and include
them
the medicaid enhancement tax the nursing
facility quality assessment railroad and
private rail car tax
excavation tax timber tax and the
statewide education property tax
one note on the medicaid enhancement tax
hospitals are required to file with the
dra a non-binding estimate as of january
15 and that estimate was approximately
284.7 million
so that's pretty strong estimates
compared to prior year
and that is all i had happy to answer
any additional questions
the the question was with respect to the
medicaid enhancement tax agreement that
was reached with the hospitals that is
fully implemented now and we're just
following what's provided in statute
nope and the rate has stabilized so we
are yep through that whole process
sure
all right
thank you
we didn't put this in the calendar but
uh
for our
own purposes we had indicated that
the next
speaker would come on at 11 o'clock
it is now 10 33
does anybody have a problem if we
go to the next
all speaker she is ready
and this next speaker will be
monica
mezzapelli
state treasurer discussing the state
financial conditions
encoding
cash flow reserves debt
and rating and bonding
so
let me introduce the treasurer monica
mezzapelli
is the new hampshire state treasurer
with the responsibility for over 200
million dollars in daily
liquidity
about 1 billion in general obligation
bonds
and other state obligations in all
treasury financial management activities
including the abandoned property program
treasurer masapali
is an ex-official member of numerous
statutory boards and commissions
is the trustee of the new hampshire 529
college saving plan
and the co-administrator of the stable
new hampshire program
treasurer mezzapelli began her career in
public accounting
joined the office
of the legislative budget assistant and
audit division in 2000
and served as deputy state treasurer for
six years prior to being appointed
commissioner of the treasury in april of
two thousand and twenty
treasurer mizzipelli graduated with a
degree in finance and accounting
from last cell
lasalle university is a certified public
accountant
and holds the
aicpa designation of chartered global
management accounting
you're on
thank you mr chairman um i'm sure so i
think i can stand here and manage the
slides so
i hope that works for everyone
so good morning everyone it's a pleasure
to be here this morning
and um
i was
asked to talk about or give you an
update on the state's financial
conditions so
that's what i intend to do today um
i'll just briefly
provide you one overview of the state
treasury talk about cash flows and our
reserves
and also give you an update on our debt
bonding and ratings
where we are right now
and hopefully have time for questions at
the end
so just as a reminder the state church
is in nonpartisan constitutional office
we are responsible for the management of
the state's financial assets and
financial liabilities
we also have the oversight of some state
programs
and that's the unclaimed property
program
we collaborate with the college tuition
service plan advisory commission on the
administration of the 529 college
savings program
and the statewide new hampshire
program is
a program that i collaborate with the
governor's commission on disabilities to
promote that program and as it was
mentioned in introduction
as you know i'm a member of several
members
several boards and commissions
apologies
okay
i'll try to continue with
okay great thanks
thank you
yes
apologize about that um
so just briefly an update on our claim
property program during fiscal year 21
we return approximately 6.3 million
in
property assets
that were reported to us and over the
last 10 years we have returned 67
million
to the rightful owner of that property
um our claim size is small so the
smallest the average claim size of the
property were returned in footscare 21
was 938 dollars and as you all know er
all the new property that we receive is
published in the new hampshire union
leader every year twice a year twice in
the year
but um anyone is able to search and
initiate a claim online just by visiting
our website new hampshire.find your
claimproperty.com
so um
we receive over 21 million 21 million
dollars by four
four thousand five hundred holders in
fiscal year twenty one and so it's about
84 million dollars over the last 10
years
so as you all know property that is not
claimed after three years is cheated to
uh county treasurers and also the
general fund in fiscal year 21 we
returned 15 million
we credited to the rent to the general
fund 50 million and on average we
returned um to the general we created
the general fund about an average of 15
million
claimants can come
forward to recover their property and
perpetuity
and
we simply go to a government council to
request permission to pay those claims
perfect
so a quick update on the college service
plan
as it was mentioned introduction of the
trustee of of the plan
and that's comprised of of two programs
two plans the unique college investing
plan a fidel advisor fighting a plan
just a tax advantage savings accounts
designed for families to save for
college the new hampshire plan is the
fourth largest in the country and right
now has about 21 billion dollars in
assets under management
from that plan the state received an
administrative assessment that is used
to fund scholarships for
low-income new hampshire students so
it's still a very strong successful plan
so moving on to a quick update on the
seven new hampshire plan this is a
growing plan um it's also a tax
advantage savings account for and this
one is for qualified individuals with
disabilities
so these accounts can grow tax-free as
long as
these individuals can use
those funds to pay for qualified
disability expenses and or expenses are
to improve their quality of life so i um
i collaborate with director chuck say on
this and
right now we have a five-year contract
with the city of ohio
to
put the host the platform for this
program
and 13 other states are part of this
plan and so new hampshire is one of them
again this program is growing and new
hampshire new hampshire residents have
opened
as of today they have opened 577
accounts and right now they're 5 million
dollars in assets under management so
we're excited that this program keeps
growing
so i just wanted to give you a quick
update on those programs but um
so
now we're ready to talk about the
state's financial condition
and as you all know
the state
began fiscal year 21
with a deficit and this chart comes from
the annual comprehensive financial
report are audited statements
financial statements and as you can see
under the fiscal year 21 columns
the general fund began with a deficit of
51 million dollars
but as you heard over the past year
new hampshire had
understood
revenue exceeded expectations
revenues came really strong and that
allowed um
to cover obviously the appropriations
and additional appropriations that were
part of
um
that were
approved
during the
recent budget process and those
additional appropriations were added to
fiscal year 21 and after that this day
finished with a surplus of about 200
million
the education trust fund obviously
performed well as well
and
this allowed
to add
to transfer from the surplus to the
rainy day fund so the state was able to
add
about 141 142 million dollars to the
rainy day fund
and so that is
the total fund balance
right now which is which is excellent so
i'll talk a little more about the rainy
day fund
in a few minutes later later in the
presentation
so i just wanted to show you this this
graph and i know you heard about all the
various taxes from commissioners uh step
but this um
this
the treasury focuses a lot on under
stick to rhino for a lot of reasons and
and just wanted to show you how
a resecular revenue has
increased over time and so over the last
10 years
as you can see since the
since the great recession new hampshire
has been able to improve revenue um
gradually improve the revenue
performance
the
the yellow or
orange line shows you how you know
the state has had you know up and downs
and for example in fiscal year 14
there was a decline of about eight
percent
but then it kept increasing after that
and then in 2020 we had another large
decline of six percent but then
extraordinary increase of 21 percent and
fiscal year 21. so prior to fiscal 21
and since the since the great recession
the state had on average grew about one
percent and then again fiscal year 201
was extraordinary and this is
clearly was thanks to the um
the fiscal policy and monetary policy um
accommodations that
that we saw at the federal level
the entire country benefited from that
our economy benefit that and the state
benefited from that as well
so that brings us to our cash flows so
our typical um
um
typical liquidity
and nutrition we oversee approximately
uh between 200 and 900 million dollars
in cash uh in fiscal year teamwork we
sold cash receipts of about 8.7 million
and
disbursements of about 8.2 billion
and that is from
payments to vendors payroll state
programs
distribution to municipalities etc we
also pay for banking cost
and by statute we are required to invest
excess liquidity anything that we don't
um that is not used for operating
expenses we
we invested in short-term instruments so
for that with the low interest rate
environment that we have right now
for the most part we use interest
bearing accounts and some mutual funds
so our investment policy
indicates that we need to preserve the
value and save to the principal provide
sufficient liquidity for financial
operations
and obviously optimize our the rate of
return
so in addition to that typical cash that
we oversee
um we also trustees in footage areas of
about over 50 trusted consortial
accounts
and
at the end of fiscal year 21 that was
over 64 million dollars
so that brings us to the additional cash
that we received um
as a result of the
coin i.t pandemic
we began
our typical cash flow changed
significantly with with the amount of
money that we received
so we started with the 1.2 billion that
were received from a cares funding
and
and that was at the end of
fiscal year 20.
and then at the end of
canada year 20
the additional properties the
coronavirus
supplemental appropriation was also
approved and that's when we saw the
first round of emergency rental
assistance program the era one money for
that we receive another
we receive 179 million dollars
then the rescue plan was approved
and we received the second round of
emergency rental assistance
money and that was 46 million dollars
we didn't receive the initial allocation
of the homeowners assistance fund we
received five million dollars to start
with and that was designed to start and
that was uh foreign expenses
and
the second allocation is
actually arrived today so i'll talk
about that in a moment
and then we receive the 497 million
dollars relative to the state and local
fiscal recovery funds
we also received 56 million that was
dedicated for municipalities and
non-entitlement units that funding was
received in june and it was distributed
to municipalities
in the beginning of the fiscal year the
first few weeks in july
but we're not done we're still in fiscal
year 22 we're expecting
an additional 122 million for the
capital projects fund that we apply for
we are also expecting
the remaining allocation of the era 2
funds that's 69 million
as i mentioned
today we actually received 45 million
which is the remaining allocation of the
homeowner's assistance fund
and
around may we're going to get the second
tranche of the state and local recovery
funds and that's going to be about 500
million
so we received about 2 billion dollars
in federal assistance
so at some point of another our cash
flow was increased by about a mil but a
billion
during
the care at the end of fiscal year 21
the cares
the state has spent about 690 million in
cares funding so the money came in and
it was distributed
and it was used for all the various
programs that were approved
to to
provide relief and and stimulus to
all the various
small businesses
self-employed as you all know
assistance to municipalities assistance
to colleges universities hospitals all
the various programs that were approved
and we're designed
by policy
so all of that cash
just simply changed you know the amount
of operating cash that we've been
handling um
we
kept the cares money in a separate bank
account just because we were not sure
how the u.s treasury was going to
you know we weren't sure if the typical
requirements that cash management
improvement act requirements were going
to apply so we kept that we weren't sure
if we need to return interest back to
the to the u.s treasury but the
guidelines came out later they said no
you don't have to return the fund the
interest um for the care's money we kept
in a separate account and that's where
it is but when when the art money was
approved then knowing that um the funds
were going to be treated the same way as
the cares money we decided to start
adding that to our pool cash and so
every time the fiscal committee approves
and accepts those fundings we move it to
our pool cash
and so this jar what is showing
if you can see the fiscal years
hopefully you can see well
fiscal year is 27 um 18 19. our typical
cash is pretty predictable is based on
the collection of our taxes is based on
the time and if we need to make
statutory payments so as you can see
hopefully able to see that we had some
years that with lower levels of cash
what is pretty predictable
typically the decline the lowest level
of or cash position is
at the end of december that's when we
had to disperse
all of the payments to municipalities
for meals and rooms we have to pay
adequate education
funds and aid to
citizen towns and catastrophic aids so
that's a that's when we are again those
that's what we have our largest largest
disbursements
and then the time tax season comes and
that's when we see uh increase in
revenue but um as you can see if you if
you are able to look at the green line
that is um that is fiscal year 20. so we
started with our cash position was very
strong at the beginning of the fiscal
year
and as a pandemic head and around april
time
and some of the tax deadlines were moved
we could see how our cash was decided to
decline at that moment so fiscal year 21
started
with less cash than typical and that's
the darker blue line
um but again with the additional revenue
performance
and
additional additional revenue that we
have been collecting and how we are
moving all the federal fund into
our operating accounts you can see how
fiscal year again fiscal year 21
finished really strong again the darker
line of
the darker blue line
and then
the red line is showing
fiscal year 22
which right now our cash levels are
about right now about about a billion
dollars but it reached about
close to
1.4 billion
early in the year
so let's bring this to our cash reserves
um so as i mentioned earlier the state
was able to add a 142 million dollars to
the rainy day fund so we now so now the
rainy day fund has 257 point million
dollars
um rsa
nikola 13
e provides us a tour framework how this
how much we can add to the rainy day
fund
so subject to limitations any surplus at
the end of the fiscal year
is to be transferred to the rainy day
fund
the maximum allowable amount is 10 of
unrestricted revenues for the most
recently completed biennium and that
as you'll know that changed during the
budget process um house bill 2 had an
amendment that
essentially increased the cap
um
how much we can add to the reign of the
funds so it would it moved it changed
from 10 percent of our receipt to random
revenue for the most recently completed
fiscal year to the most recently
completed biennium so essentially
doubling the capacity of how much we can
add to the rainy day fund
so um you know with 3.3 billion in
unrestricted revenue for the biennium
the cap right now is 236 million dollars
and so um
with a balance of 257.8 million so our
capacity right now is about
7.7 percent
so this is um
this is the rating agencies typically
support uh maximizing the amount that we
can enter in the fund so um i can see
how this will be a credit positive
for new hampshire
and
there are
new hampshire is not unique um
you know increasing the the reserves
most states were able to do that some
states in the country don't have a cap
and they were able to add more than 10
percent
but all over the country that
states had strong performances they were
able to add to the rainy day fund the
way
new hampshire did
this slide just talks about the
mechanics of
how the rainy day fund is used
funds can only be transferred out if the
conditions are met if there is a budget
deficit that occurred for the most
recently completed biennium and also if
under situated general fund were in
revenues for short of the budgeted
amount
the
the it has to be the lesser of the
budget deficit or revenue shortfall
so the comptroller has to request
permission of the fiscal committee of
the governor and
the transfer is made and if transfers
out of for any other reason need to be
approved by the governor and two-thirds
of each chamber in the legislature
so this just this just graph is trying
to show you
how the rainy day fund has changed over
the last 10 years
so duran so from 2012 through 2014 the
rainy day balance the rainy day fund had
9.3 million dollars
then it increased to 22.3 million
and in 2016 it increased
to 93 million and then
again in 2018
it was 110 million in 2019 it was 115
million to stay there
also
it remained that way
in fiscal year 20 and again
the significant change that occurred
fiscal year 21
now having 257 million
so that brings us to our debt management
program
and
as of june 30 the state had about one
billion dollars in bonds outstanding
695 million
was relative to our geo bonds and that
is
compared to fiscal year 20 we had
741 million outstanding
as you all know we should bonds
to
finance our capital projects
and this borrowing is backed by the full
faith and credit of this state
of those year bonds 70 of
the debt service is made from
unrestricted general fund revenue any
other
and the rest of the debt services pay
with
dedicated sources of funding
so we use a rapid amortization schedule
we typically we we pay those um
in 20 years and we pay 60
of
our principal and during the first 10
years and the rest is paid in the final
10 years
the last time we issued bonds was in
december of 2020. at that time we issued
49.5 million of geo bonds and
37.5 million of geo refund bonds and at
that time we we achieved present net
present value savings of approximately
11 million so
during the time we welcome the
additional cash that we received
we are getting ready to issue more bonds
and this we're planning on a sale in in
march of this year so we're working uh
right now towards that
so we also work with the department of
department transportation transportation
and we oversee the turnpike revenue
bonds and at the at the end of fiscal
year 21
there were 271 million dollars
outstanding of those bonds this debt
service has paid from turnpike uh total
revenues
and also we oversee the the garvey bonds
and at the end of the fiscal year as
75.8 million were outstanding it is that
service is pay from federal highway from
funds received from the federal highway
administration
we also have bonds authorized at an
issue
of 573 million and of that is
224 million relate to
geo bonds
this graph is just showing how our debt
is trending lower and
is as the reason as i mentioned
we use a rapid amortization schedule
also we haven't we haven't issued bonds
since december 2020
and
for uh the turbine bonds they uh also
haven't they have an issue bonds in
several years they had a refund then in
2019 they don't have plans to issue any
more bonds at this moment and so um they
just keep paying their service and
that's how we're seeing
their debt levels are trending lower and
that's uh clearly um
seen as positive by the rating agencies
credit rating agencies
with our low
debt levels
so as you'll know our borrowing as
largely influenced by the
the state's created rating
so the grading agencies
evaluate and assess sustained financial
conditions different the
financial operations of the state
and they focus on particularly on the
levels of the rainy day fund
how
you know if how the budget is managed if
it's
a balanced budget
and how the states manage their ability
to control those um
those the spending
they also look at um
i guess on that on the prior point and
they typically look at for example right
now the the rating agencies will be
interested in seeing how the state
manage all this additional funding that
we receive from the federal government
they want to see that one-time revenues
are used for one-time expenses and that
additional revenues are not increasing
the programs that could create budgetary
pressures
so similar to right now the rating
agents are interested in seeing how
states manage their medicaid programs
with increased eligibility um obviously
they could there could be some budgetary
pressure pressures and now some of the
assistance that the medicaid program has
received from the federal government
when that stops the additional funding
um you know it is important to it will
be important to to
to see how the state manages that the
case loads and in
and again to to prevent any budgetary
pressures
they also look at the the pension
post-atomic benefit obligations and
their funding levels
the
rating agencies
have seen that new hampshire has
improved the way the pension obligations
have been funded
they were pleased to see that the
retirement system lowered the
assumed rate of return with more
realistic expectations and how there is
a discipline in how the state plans to
fund the unfunded liability over the
next 18 years and again they have seen
even though there's still a
lot of funded liability again is that
discipline that they look at how new
hampshire could achieve the ultimate
goal of paying that unfunded liability
so they look at stability and diversity
of revenue sources new hampshire has a
strong mix of various
taxes it doesn't rely on one or two
taxes like other states do so this is a
strong point for new hampshire
when one tax is not performing well then
there are others that that have been
able to um
just like we saw in fiscal year 21 meals
in rooms
was not performant as well but then we
have business taxes that took care of
our concerns and in
revenue succeeded expectations
and again they look at you know how the
states manage
in in difficult times you know how
they're able to manage revenues
expenditures and their reserves so um
the rating agencies were curious to see
how new hampshire was going to manage
the pandemic and how
you know during the economic downturn
how new hampshire was going to manage
the expenses so through executive order
the governor
froze
hiring and there were
there were reductions in spending so
while the economy was recovering
you know the fact that new hampshire was
able to control their spending
is also what the rating agencies see and
in in their observing and they like to
see that the states can manage that
so there's been increased interest in
how states manage cyber security risk
and
whether the states are prepared for
cyber attack ransomware
they want to know how how strong and
want to hear a little more about how
prepared states are and if there are if
there is
insurance to cover that you know if it's
too expensive can they afford that
um so again another point they just want
to be able to see that a state in
issuers are not
you know their economy is not impacted
because of you know an event of this
nature
and recently they've had increased
interest in in
what is environmental social and
governance factors the esg factors
they look at this at the global
level because they rate um
globally
so so in terms of states issuers
states are strong they have a strong
governance and social
convictions so there's really not a lot
of concern there's transparency states
have transparency so that's not compared
to other countries uh obviously is that
not a concern in terms of what the
rating agencies uh in their view but
there but in their but they're what's
what's evolving now is how the
scientists see the environmental piece
which relates to how states are prepared
to
respond to disasters um
events of you know that nature
how they're going to transition from
carbon to
renewable energy and how that's going to
impact economy so anything to do with
with those points
they've always considered that and but
they're just most recently they are
assigned to
formalize their methodology what they
call the esg methodology so we're seeing
that more and more
so
the um
which is
the current um
the current look by the rating agencies
of the public sector is stable they
believe that what all these stimulus and
funding all the states have received
they are being able to
just like we saw in new hampshire are
able to manage the economy the finances
be able to um
perform for well
and um right now some of the uh the
concerns that they are
raising is how states are going to
manage for example covet variants you
know how per house how the states are
going to continue to manage to spend
them and how is that going to impact the
economy
also how the states are going to respond
to these this inflationary
pressures and
the ongoing supply chain issues
the labor force challenges and so they
want to be able to see how the state is
is managing that in particular in new
hampshire they're concerned about the
demographic trends
how this shrinking
working age is is is really going is
going to impact
this state's economy they have been
monitoring that for several years and
that's something that obviously the
state needs to
keep
being mindful of those of those
pressures that could impact
the state's economy and finances
so this is the current ratings and um we
haven't been formally reviewed since the
last time we issue bonds that was in
december 2020 so with
just
the public information that is available
the rating agencies were able to affirm
our current ratings and we have we
continue to have strong
strong ratings and
again we'll be evaluated pretty soon
when we get it ready to
for our bond sale and so we'll have
uh they're gonna we're gonna have the
opportunity to have conversations with
the rain age disease and talk about all
the various things
new hampshire has done over the last
fiscal year and and some of the
initiatives that were included in in the
budget and some of the
again the successes of new hampshire
and so we'll try to do our best job
several state officials and myself
participate in this call so we'll do all
we can um to highlight all the good
things about our state
and lastly i just wanted to add
the dashboard many of you are familiar
with this this dashboard i just wanted
to mention that that's updated on a
monthly basis i update that on a monthly
basis and we post that online so
if you ever want to know of our cash
position
or anything about our
bond level um bonus standard levels and
ratings is that's what's um captured
on this dashboard
and and that concludes my presentation
for today i'll be happy to answer any
questions
thank you monica
before we take any questions
earlier this morning we talked about the
rainy day fund with the legislative
budget
officer and then
the dra
and
it indicates on your thing
257 to 257.8
million dollars rainy day
which is the same with as they use
but
when you look take a look at it
we have
money in our hands
from the ppp loans that were taxed
that
changed the law in house bill 2 and that
money is going to have to be refunded it
could be up to 100 million dollars
we also have
such thing as credit carryover
which
in not so many years has gone from about
130 million to about 290 million dollars
and neither one of these things are our
money
but they
figure into the
rainy day fund
should there be a note
on your state financial condition
relative to the rainy day fund at
about the credit card over and the
ppp loans
it's a great question i think um because
and this is this is a current statute
because there was a surplus that's why
the state was able to add those you know
that additional funding into the rainy
day fund
so if i would i would imagine that if
though if the funds that your you just
mentioned needed to be returned it would
have to be in you know as part of the
budget and so that will impact
essentially the next biennium and that's
what
hopefully we don't have to we don't have
a deficit that will you know ultimately
impact you know how much the rainy
defunct
could have
so it really is a budgetary
it's not um it will be a budgetary
impact
what will impact the amount that we keep
in our reserves
if that makes sense
okay so that
the budget would show it as the revenue
went back to the owners
and then that would show a negative
effect eventually so to reduce the rainy
day fund in the future right if there is
a deficit yes it will have to come from
the rainy day fund
but i think it will have to be until the
end of the next biennium just according
to statue unless there is you know this
this one time you know the only other
time that
the governor and and the legislature
will have to approve
taking money out of the rainy day fund
you know if it's not at the end of the
biennium and in the meantime
we can
use that rainy day fund
to get
good ratings
it is a good thing i have to say that
questions
representative bromley
thank you madam chair madam treasurer
great job um
so we know i think we've established
that the rainy day fund's a real
important factor for uh bond ratings
but
and i've heard these presentations over
a bunch of years
and it's well established but this first
time i've heard about cyber security
can you just touch on that a little bit
as to what the state is doing in that
area that would be helpful
united technical maybe we have the i.t
people at some point tell us what's
going to say that perhaps i'm not going
to be able to give you the right answer
but my understanding you know the
department of information technology is
working with
governor's office and to strengthen
obviously the security of our systems
and
i believe the state has insurance for
that i know that can be very expensive
there are times that
honestly right now at this moment i'm
not really sure the status of insurance
but i know that's also part of that
concern and we typically you know
we when we prepare our information
statement when we're getting ready to
issue bonds we update the section of
cyber security and
the commissioner usually participates
and adds information the current
information so we're currently working
on that
to update that information but it is
important to
obviously there are pieces that we can
completely um disclose for secure
reasons but they
but we just need to show enough
information to say that we are
prepared to to handle
an event of that nature
do we have
representative
back here
hi
on well two procedural things first
i hope gen 4 can send us the color
version of these slides because they're
impossible to
follow otherwise
digitally she doesn't have to do it on
paper
on
and
it would be nice if you'd restore
sending us a quarterly dashboard
right you don't have to produce this
economic analysis that the previous
treasurer was doing
but
sure so on what i wanted to
i'm glad my colleague asked the question
about the ppp and this and the credit
carry forward i don't know if that's
going to
affect your cash availability
if it
uh if most of that hundred million from
the ppp for instance uh got had to be
refunded
uh in
in
may june i think it'd have to be done by
uh
but
on the other question i had was
i was here
for the great recession
and
there was a lot of stimulus money that
went out for too short a time
and it was tied to a lot of federal
regulation which this one is also
and the the executives set up a system
which i think the treasury was involved
in
that
on
helped
oversaw the towns and the counties
reporting correctly and the agencies of
the state reporting correctly so that we
wouldn't get in trouble with the feds
is there something like that going on
now and are you involved in it or
um
so um i know for example um
they go for office and who are mainly
responsible for
managing this grant so we we we have
been
um the treasury we we have been applying
for those grants
the way we've been managing this
addition all this fun you know all this
federal financial assistance that we're
receiving is for the most part the go
for office is
managing the program itself and the
compliance piece
so collaborating with you know the
gopher office
a little bit the treasury and
administrative services because they
also look at
for audit purposes
they want to make sure that we all
obviously in compliance with all the
various
requirements of this program so yes it
is all part of if this will be will be
audited as part of the signal audit that
the state goes through
so i i know for for certain that all of
those
regulations and i know the governance
office also is involved with reviewing
the regulations to make sure that we are
managing this funds
you know the way it was intended in the
in the the federal level
with the federal statute
um
you had a separate question well i think
you're correct so so if we if we see
funds that are going to be dispersed
because we're collected and all of a
sudden we we have cash that we shouldn't
have
obviously that could impact our cash
position
what i have to say right in our cash
position is so strong that i am not
concerned if we if we lose a few
hundred million dollars
of course that's going to change over
time as as we are bringing all of these
federal
funds and we pull them with our cash we
we have the advantage to
really um you know just as such we just
have all this extra cash that we're not
that concerned
about liquidity we had those concerns
back in december we december 2020 um
the beginning of fiscal year 21 was a
difficult year for us we were concerned
that we were not going to have enough
funds to pay our obligations
we were concerned that we need to borrow
money we didn't want to borrow money
so that was a period of time that we had
to watch our liquidity but right now we
don't have that situation
again the funding that we receive from
the federal government
it doesn't it did
the only difference between this one
time with all the stimulus that we see
we received and
any other program is that we receive all
this funding up front so now we have all
this cash the government for government
doesn't doesn't function that way they
usually say you spend the money then
we'll reimburse you after this time was
completely different it was with a clear
intention to inject economy to bring the
economy back to how i was before
at the national level at the state level
and it did work um as we could see it
the way we see it so
again i'm not as concerned if we have to
spend some money just because it was a
little bit of a glitch from some of
the treatments
of some programs
i think i answer your two questions
further questions
saying monica thank you very much thank
you i just want to add one more thing i
would like to say um with all the
federal funding that were received
obviously we're going to have a strong
cash position for
for some time but that clearly is going
to change as the state agencies um start
spending that money so things are going
to change i would say
by the end you know
fiscal year 23 24 all the money needs to
be spent or it needs to be obligated by
december 2026. so um again probably we
don't have to worry about you know in
terms of cash we don't have a lot to
worry about but as the obviously our
cash position and our
net cash flow will change over time and
we just
obviously will continue to watch that
from our standpoint
and that's all thank you very much
thank you
we appreciate your
presentation
thank you
okay we're a little early but that's
okay
um
being 11 21
11 30
your schedule so
you're ready aren't you okay then the
next presentation
is going to be from taylor caswell
commission of the department of business
and economic affairs
discussing the state's economy
encoding business activity and the
impact of the stimulus funds on
businesses in the state
taylor caswell
is the first commissioner
as the first commissioner of the new
hampshire department of business and
economic affairs
first appointed the position in 2017
he serves as the chief economic and
marketing official for the state and
oversees the state division of economic
development and travel and tourism
development
since september of 2020
casual has also served as the head of
the governor's office for emergency
relief recovery called gopher
with the responsibility for transparent
development
deployment
and management of more than two billion
dollars in federal covert relief and
stimulus funds
casual experience in the private sector
include structuring and funding
renewable power and affordable housing
development
financial services and government
relations works for 14 for a fortune
500 energy company
taylor our commissioner it's yours
before you start second announcement
um for the members i'm just gonna be
around to update your um your printout
for this one the one in your packets is
missing a few slides
and i apologize
and i apologize to your group because
um the file just did not play well with
our printer and so this packet it goes
one two three four
two three four so i apologize and i will
also um blast out the
link that has all of the presentations
online if you have a device that you'd
like to follow along on
thank you guys thank you
well sure morning everybody uh
good to see you
uh
a lot has happened since the last time
we got together
in terms of the economy and everything
that's been going on so it's good to
give you a little bit of an update i
know after i think later on today you're
hearing from employment security and
bridge slavers and his group
i should point out before i start we
work very very closely with obviously
with employment security as well as with
the treasurer's office the governor's
office and everyone else but uh
employment security and our department
have really in terms of managing what's
been going on over the last couple of
months and keeping track of the data and
all that it's been a very much of a
shared experience
so i think you'll probably be able to
see some continuity between what i'm
going to talk about here
in my presentation and what you'll hear
about from commissioner capacity deputy
commissioner
later on today
so
ba has been very much involved in
everything that's been going on since we
hit the pandemic now almost two years
ago
and i wanted to kind of give you a
little bit of a flavor
oh i'm gonna scroll like this
about one of the major components
of what we've been up to over the last
year and a half now is the development
of an economic recovery strategy that is
giving us a bit of a roadmap
i can do it for you i can double team i
can i can do the whole thing i
appreciate that
if anyone can hear me i'll just keep
going like this if that works
just stop
um
so i think when we do
let's go back two years we're really
looking at a pre-pandemic situation
economically speaking in the state that
was really quite good
we were seeing very low unemployment
rates we were seeing heavy investment a
lot of business activity
and so on and so forth we hit
right about march of 2020 and everything
just started to really change
and
what we had been up to up to that point
is really working on
a long-term economic development
strategy
but once we sort of saw what was
beginning to happen and where we thought
things were going to go and what
opportunities and challenges that were
going to be facing us
going forward we felt we had to realign
a lot of that operation that's a little
bit of what i wanted to talk to you
about today so here is um obviously that
very shocking graph of our unemployment
rate and what happened in uh march and
april of 2020 where we jumped to a 16
unemployment rate
nationally that's the other line at 14.7
and then over the course of the last uh
now almost year and a half we've seen
just an incredible reduction of that
unemployment rate
this doesn't tell the whole story
as many of you are well aware that we
still have labor force shortages going
on
and there's a lot behind this data
the federal government which is
responsible for this data
really doesn't change a lot of the way
that they calculate that and it's pretty
standard been going on for many years
this is
a good harbinger a good way to see sort
of how we're doing against other states
but in my view it's not always the best
indication as to what's actually
happening in our
workforce so one of the things as this
all began was we felt very strongly that
we wanted to make investments quickly
and efficiently into the state economy
to sort of shore up what we were seeing
happening particularly with our small
business community and this is jumping
back again a little bit two years but we
had it's important to remember that
there were two
major tranches of recovery and relief
funding that came to the state
a good portion of that obviously was for
public health
and for all of the
initiatives and programs that had to be
funded in order to fight and covet and
are continuing to do so
our department
really was focused on what are we going
to be doing with those resources as it
relates to the economy and the
investments that we need to be making in
those respects so under cares act which
came in spring of 2020
that was 1.25 billion dollars as you'll
recall
roughly a little less than half of that
money ended up going into
i can go to the next slide going into
business support specifically and we
moved pretty quickly with things like
the main street relief fund and the self
program and the there was the gap
program and we had a program
specifically for non-profits
just basically to get some resources out
to our employers early into this
pandemic we were one of the first states
really to be able to do that and i think
you know when you look at that number
that graph that i showed earlier and how
quickly that
that unemployment number started to dive
back down i think a lot of that had to
do with the fact that we were able to
keep a lot of businesses
not all of them of course but a lot of
businesses in a lot of sectors
functional and able to continue to
employ people
as we move towards the
the arpa funds which came in just about
a year ago now
the american rescue plan funds those
have a much longer
horizon to them as monica pointed out we
have until 2026
to fully expend those resources
as opposed to the cares act which was
really initially at least just a couple
of months they did extend that deadline
for those of you that are on fiscal
committee agreement are well aware
until for an additional year but
these funds are going to be good going
out until 2026. so that does change the
little bit of the flavor of those
resources and has put us into a mode of
really being able to focus on what are
the specific long-term one-time types of
investments that we could be making that
could be fundamentally valuable to our
employers to our economy
for many years to come not just within
the most immediate need that we have so
if you look under american rescue plan
here on this slide we've broken it down
into a couple of areas where thus far
fiscal committee and government council
and gopher and all of the parties
involved in that effort
have authorized funds along the lines
thus far with these numbers about 28
million dollars of that going to
economic development
roughly about 20 million dollars so far
has gone to workforce development
initiatives
and uh the the 30 million dollars that
you see there for broadband and cyber
security
that has gone but that number is going
to grow very very substantially
over the next couple of months and i'll
probably get a chance to talk about that
in a few minutes
so going back to what i mentioned
earlier what we really wanted to be able
to do was get all of the see these
resources see what the needs were out
there
go through a process
of really getting back out to
stakeholders partners businesses get an
assessment as to what the situation is
there what are the needs how have they
changed substantially if at all
from pre-pandemic conditions and boil
that down into a number of really basic
plans and strategies that we have put
forward called the economic recovery and
expansion strategy this was issued on
our
back earlier this year in 2021 and it
has served as a lot of the basis for the
activity of ba and the department
working again with employment security
and our other partners in state
government but also it has given us a
little bit of a road map and a strategy
to follow as it relates to the american
rescue plan
proposals that we've been putting
forward
there are five basic goals under the
we'll call it the aries plan economic
recovery strategy
number one of course is the labor force
retain and recruit a modern workforce
our economy has been on a trajectory now
for several years
of a really sort of highly experienced
highly qualified highly educated uh
positions or where we're seeing the
highest growth whether that's in health
care whether that's in technology that's
the type of entrepreneurial startups
that we're seeing uh and so on and so
forth so a lot of our activity has been
how do we find those individuals how do
we get them to new hampshire how do we
keep the
the
labor force that we do have that
qualifies into that into those
categories and assist our employers in
their need to be able to continue to
grow
one way that we do do that and is
connected to
the first point there is the what we
call the connecting of new hampshire's
world-class tourism assets to town
recruit
so this is tourist tourist to town
basically we really and i feel pretty
strongly that uh you know our tourism
industry which has been you know pretty
well ravaged during 2020 but showed some
extreme strength this past year and i
have some data on that
before we're done here today but
that really serves as an entry point for
a lot of people to fully understand
what is it about living in new hampshire
what are the quality of life in
components that really are appealing to
the demographics that we're seeking to
be able to draw to new hampshire
and
the best to the extent that what we're
seeing the demographics that we have
traditionally sought in new hampshire
has been sort of that younger family
people that are maybe in their second or
third job
looking for a place to raise a family or
to really increasingly
look for that work life balance
which i think we have seen an increase
in the audience that is receptive to
those uh those marketing appeals
as a result of the pandemic
and there have been some pretty
encouraging numbers along those lines i
know that there's
often a lot of discussion around various
components of our
demographic trends one though that i
certainly like to highlight is the fact
that if you look at our net migration
numbers over the last several years the
the numbers of people that are coming to
new hampshire versus the number of
people that are leaving we've been on
the upside of that now for about five
years uh and each year it grows a little
bit more
and in fact this year
2021 i should say
we saw that number grow to 13
hundred again
not a huge game changer not gonna
fill every position that we have open in
the state but really to continue to see
that positive trend moving in a
direction and again and i would say that
also within that within that group a
good 75 to 80 percent of that 13 000 are
within let's the 25 to 40
uh age range which is really that's what
we're targeting so
i like to sort of see that that
perhaps some of this effort that we've
been
working on now for the past couple years
is having some positive impact and
putting us on a good trend
building resiliency in high growth
sectors i just mentioned this i mean we
see technology really growing quickly
advanced manufacturing uh healthcare
jobs
you know we i don't need to go on about
the situation in the healthcare
employment sector right now but it's
still regardless of what's happening
under cobit it's going to continue to
grow as it was pre-pandemic
hospitality industry
providing us that entree into new
hampshire
and whether it's restaurants or whether
it's tourist attractions whether it's
hotels those are huge employers in our
state and we need to be and we're highly
focused on
the efforts on those sectors
technology i mentioned in construction
construction industry was growing
pre-pandemic again
as we start to see the infusion of funds
coming from the federal infrastructure
legislation
that will start showing up here at some
point soon
that's going to continue to even put
more pressure on the labor needs of that
industry
and so again those are there's five
those five sectors are where we're
really heavily focused
the entrepreneurial component
state we are seeing large numbers of
business formations not just in new
hampshire but
across the united states
new hampshire has always been a place
that's been open to
new startups new businesses
entrepreneurism
working closely now increasingly with
our university system to help facilitate
more of that activity giving students
coming out of our undergraduate
institutions an opportunity to stay in
new hampshire and open a business in new
hampshire by solidifying some of those
relationships that they have and some of
the
programs that are offered at those at
our universities is very much
part of this aspect of our strategy
and then the role of infrastructure
i don't think i need to go in too much
about that obviously roads bridges and
so on but included in this increasingly
and where we're seeing investment in uh
some of these federal resources that are
coming into the state they're in water
and sewer
which is critical i mean there are areas
of the state that still don't have
adequate water sewer for
to be able to manage the growth that
they're seeing or that they're seeking
to be able to have and then broadband
is very much part of this
broadband right now
the state under uh american rescue plan
is
going to see an infusion of around 122
million dollars for broadband
implementation across the state it's
primarily focused on unserved and
underserved areas
this is going to fundamentally change
the landscape
once we're able to start moving programs
and moving those funds
out into our communities to make those
changes and to get the state wired up
because it's really hard to participate
in the economy in the 21st century if
you don't have high speed access to the
internet
so excuse me i've started to get into a
little bit of that here are some of the
main areas that are obvious to those of
us who work in this space business
retention keeping the businesses that we
have in the state continuing to work in
our business attraction area business
recruitment and expansion we have a
whole team that works on this on a daily
basis and this is work that has changed
fundamentally as a result of the
pandemic
virtual
recruitment of companies to come to new
hampshire is a new thing and all states
are learning how to i think adapt to
that uh we're trying to stay very much
ahead of that curve and have made some
investments to try to keep our team able
to compete
for businesses looking to expand just
the fact that
a business can expand in just so many
different ways now it doesn't need to
necessarily buy a huge new facility
move a facility to a new state they can
seek workforce they can seek
labor across the country now with remote
working and
virtual access to the labor markets
which is really changing the landscape
out there as to how all of this work uh
workforce development we've talked about
entrepreneurship technical assistance
was something that bea was heavily
involved with throughout the pandemic
working with businesses working with
communities to try to make sure that
people were getting the assistance they
needed and if they had questions or if
they needed some guidance getting them
to those resources
either within state government or
otherwise has been something that our
staff at va has been very heavily
involved with
financing obviously infrastructure
advocacy and regulatory piece there is
one that i wanted to harp on a little
bit because
this is an area that i refer to as the
economic development infrastructure in
the state
i think if i go to the next slide
one of the ways that we're instituting
a new way to adapt to
all of the changes that i've been
talking about here has been through our
collaborative economic development
regions which we've been working on as
part of the re strategy to set up across
the state to provide regionalization
of a lot of these strategies that we've
been talking about here
what nes what the strategies and what
the priorities are for a seacoast based
economy are quite different than what we
would see in the upper valley or in the
north country and we want to be able to
have some ability to work with so many
of our partners out there whether
they're planning commissions whether
they're development corporations whether
they're individual communities
employers and so on
to be able to adjust the specific needs
that they're seeing in those regions and
so this is a little bit of an overlay
and i know many of you work in the space
now there's a lot of different regions
and a lot of different boundary lines
already out there across the various
state agencies but for the purposes of
economic and community development i
think that in making some change to the
economic infrastructure that we use to
sort of deploy resources and to
address the issues that
we're seeing as really critical to the
growth of our economy having the
capability to do that on a regional
basis is pretty critical
this is one of our longer slides with
some of the information as to what that
these cedars are but there are four
the seacoast region
we have the central southern region
basically from concord to nashua we have
a southwestern new hampshire region that
includes cheshire and sullivan county
and then our north country
region is just now getting underway
right now but they again are populated
with all of the organizations that do
this work on a regular basis to really
continue to help grow so some of the
areas where you know we might see some
change and some examples of how this
could work
in one one example i use a lot is in the
business recruitment space
in a lot of places now if you're a
business or you're the state and we're
looking to help business move into an
area of the state
the capability and the capacity in
different areas of
across new hampshire is quite different
and a lot of times that either falls
specifically on
an individual community or it falls
the state as the driver for that
activity and for those uh
communications it takes a lot of
investment to get a company to make a
decision to move to a certain area of
the state with the cedars in place we're
able to work with
the workforce training components that
are there because that's usually what
businesses are looking for access to
workforce
work with our community college outlets
with our university system partners that
are within those regions to come up and
formulate a holistic strategy to help
bring those businesses to that area that
are otherwise it was a pick and choose
sort of as you went along
the collaboration
in this state is so critical and it is
really
something that i often hear about from
businesses
who are going through the experience of
considering moving to new hampshire that
they're able to get access to and be
able to see collaboration among so many
different parties in the state
and that's a big reason as to why they
ultimately
may or may make a decision to come here
to new hampshire so
instituting that to me is a really
critical part of what we're able to do
going forward
i had mentioned a little bit of how
we're beginning to use some of our
tourism assets to address the issues of
workforce availability in the state
and you know here we've got from play
here to stay here
everyone's got a catchy slogan as to how
these
programs can come together but as i
mentioned we are seeing some
some
results from this that are very positive
and
there's a couple of small examples here
i can provide these to you uh through
links so you can see them in bigger up
close on your on your computer screens
but we have taken a lot of the tourism
assets that we typically use to
for that industry and for that purpose
and translated them into how do we get
those individuals to recognize that you
know if the places that you like to go
kayaking or skiing on the weekends
there's a lot fewer people there on
tuesday afternoons and you can really
you can take your kids skiing during the
week or you can have that quality of
life
component that really is driving so many
of the decisions that people are making
across the country as to what does their
post pandemic work life experience
looked like so we're trying very hard to
take full advantage of that
as much as we can
a couple more ads here
these are our tourism ads for this
winter and for last summer
there is a uh i could send you some of
our tv ads i was going to play that here
today but i'm betting that that's
probably not going to work if i try that
but the last couple of slides here are
really on the fact that just earlier
this week
we
we announced that 2021 was a
record-breaking year for tourism in new
hampshire
we saw more people come to the state of
the course of 2021 than we've seen any
year
previous and in fact summer 2021
set a record for a single season
total visitor spending was over 2
billion dollars in just the summer
and that was true across the entire
state it wasn't just in the white
mountains it wasn't just in the seacoast
it was in every region of the state
and so i think you know we could
pontificate about many different reasons
as to why that may be
but uh i do know that we made a very
concerted effort to not entirely leave a
lot of the marketing and advertising
that we had been doing during the
pandemic we did not abandon key markets
we stayed in there and said things like
you know
you can't come right now but when you
can we're here and we're ready for you
we stayed front of mind in places like
new york and connecticut and rhode
island and other key in massachusetts
and key markets and i do think that that
led to a little bit of our capability to
draw those individuals to new hampshire
when we came out of the box and we knew
that it was going to be a competitive
summer when we get to the point of
having vaccines in place and having
people feel safe
to be able to get out and explore i
would also say another huge component of
this is the access to the outdoors and
the outdoor recreation component of this
any of you up in the white mountains
area or in the lakes region
or in the seacoast saw the number of
people that were getting outside last
summer was very substantial
it creates a whole new set of challenges
but at the same time it is taking what
is one of our strongest assets as a
state and putting it to work
for our tourism industry but also
hopefully as i said integrating that
into our long-term workforce strategy
these are just some of the numbers that
we had
for fiscal 21 five and a half billion
dollars worth of total spending
generating about 323 million dollars in
tax revenue uh through
meals tax
and that is a return on investment so
for every dollar that we spent in
marketing
for this on behalf of the state we saw a
return in tax revenue 12
and 8 cents
and in the summer specifically we had
2.1 billion so almost half of that
spending was in the summer uh with four
almost four and a half million visitors
to new hampshire during that period of
time
so i went through a whole bunch of stuff
there but i really wanted to give you a
sense in a bit of a lead into some of
the some of the data that you'll see
from rich and george later
on specifics around labor markets and
the unemployment rates and the
unemployment trust funds
and give you a sense of the overlaying
strategy and what we're doing
with them and with our partners
to help continue to manage our economy
and see it grow over the next couple of
years
so with that i'm happy to take any
questions mr
thank you commissioner questions for the
commissioner
uh rep senator geider followed by
representative
elmir you commissioner taylor for for
coming today
i guess my question is one about
demographics of the 25 to 40 year group
that we're trying to bring in
uh is it safe to assume they're looking
for this cedar type collaborative
process regionalized throughout the
state
is that is that attracting more than we
would if we didn't do that
or is it too soon to say
well the cedars have been in place
for
more than a year at this point but what
it's doing so for example
up in the upper valley area
we've been working really closely with
the chamber in that region and
they have instituted a lot of these same
sorts of strategies where they've
typically been very business oriented
chamber
they're looking at ways to utilize some
of the tourism marketing programs
and they're but they're not using them
specifically to attract tourists they're
using it to integrate into their
business recruitment and to share that
with their employers
and with their members so that they can
also use that
that's a good point that i should also
just elaborate on briefly is some of the
resources that the department of
business and economic affairs is
receiving under the arpa fund and under
through the eda has been to create a lot
of these types of creative assets that
you're seeing here whether they're high
quality
photographs or they're high quality
videos that typically are beyond the
reach of a local chamber or a local
business really a small business that
wants to recruit individuals we're going
to open source all of that out all of
that material so everyone will be able
to pick and choose kind of what works
for them
you know
pictures of any number of different
activities and different positions so
i'm kind of excited about that because
it'll give the chambers and the cedars
and the employers
an opportunity to pull down some of
those resources that the state is
invested in and use them to grow
representative
apologies i've got a couple of questions
on
first on because you were just talking
about the cedars i do not understand how
you're dividing them up where is the
upper valley
the upper valley is in the southwestern
cedar maybe
southwest with king
so cheshire county and sullivan county
okay that's weird
thank you
then
what are at least our biggest problem i
think the biggest problem across the
state
is where do we house workers
because they come
to look at a job and then they leave
because they can't afford our cost of
housing
and when they do afford our cost of
housing they get they
evict
our essential workers that are that are
necessary to those people's
comfort
and
i haven't really heard anything
trying
to
increase
the interest in
secondary schools
and
technical colleges in construction
in
repair
in all of the trades that go into
keeping housing viable
and
in fact in claremont just a few days ago
they took away half of their tech
center's budget
they have a tech center we don't we have
to go to vermont
you're going to bring that into a
question
so that that
question is are you going to are you
trying to do something about this
about housing
about
on
increasing the number of people who are
going in into construction
and
the trades that keep housing
going well and also buildings for
businesses yes ma'am so there's there
are a number of
programs that are in existence right now
that we're hoping to amplify we're still
in the process this is under the arpa
investment process
around workforce and workforce training
those programs have not you know
been fully proposed yet so but i can
tell you that there is intention to get
at uh
initiatives to include
the ability for employers to train their
existing employees but also
programs that will allow individuals to
seek the type of training that they that
they feel they want to have for their
career
on specifically on the trades program
there is some discussion around how can
we make some investments of arpa
resources to help
grow the capability for local high
schools to really expand their opera
their
offerings in that space either in
partnership with an existing training
school or program or on their own so
those are i would say in process but i
would say that the issues that you're
raising i would acknowledge entirely
whether it's housing or whether it's
training or whether it's a workforce
component
as it relates to
any issues around
difficulty paying rent
we have the emergency rental program
that is now almost about to cross 90
million dollars worth of investment made
of federal resources under that program
through the new hampshire housing
finance authority so if there are
instances where you have constituents or
others who are in that situation
we should get them to the new hampshire
housing finance authority to that
program because it is designed
specifically for that purpose but yes
let me just acknowledge all the things
that you said around housing and
training and so on and say those are
very much part of our broader strategy
in terms of real life on the ground
where are we going to make investments
those decisions are underway right now
yeah
if i could on that one
we need a
incredibly strong culture change
because we have been teaching the
parents and the students for 40 years
that they should go to college and they
should work with their minds instead of
with their hands and that's the way it
was put
it's
it's difficult
but
if we don't have housing we aren't going
to have people
i couldn't we just and the
in in lebanon
the hospital is now trying to
cannibalize the high-tech
workforce by
locking up
on
bids on apartments
in the area because they're about to add
400 jobs
you're hitting on the key point which is
the availability of housing
you know up in your area i know we're at
like zero percent one percent vacancy
rates it's not that different in other
areas of the state
a healthy vacancy rate in a healthy
housing environment is in a three to
five percent range so i think a lot of
what we're aiming to do strategically is
to move us in that direction how do we
increase the availability of housing
and what are the investments necessary
and what are they what is available
under the federal regulations to take
advantage of this moment in time to make
some of those one-time investments
that move us in that direction
thank you can i ask one
totally different question
which is a question go ahead thanks
uh
how can we find out what the other
322 million dollars that have already
been allocated in our are
you go to the gopher website and you
there's a there's we keep an updated
list of all of the programs and charts
and everything about how that
is being obligated right now but there's
no
categorization the way you've done for
these other three
programs
i believe there is some categorization
in what's up there right now
okay
thank you
any further questions
representation
thank you and thank you for the
presentation
i was just thinking i i've
as a landlord i've run into actually a
couple new tenants who have come from
places like
new york actually two of them from new
york and both of them are motivated to
leave new york and come to new hampshire
for
safety reasons they see new hampshire as
a safe state
and i don't think we talk about that
much we talk about you know the beauty
of new hampshire you know all the things
that we should be talking about the
beauty of new hampshire
things that we can do here live play
work and so forth
does it make sense to potentially it may
be already doing this does it make sense
to start pushing the safety aspect of it
especially as we see craziness going
around in several
cities
unfortunately new hampshire has remained
a fairly safe state and i guess the
follow-up is also
do you have
business leaders or anyone
that's thinking about new hampshire ask
you about you know the safety aspect of
this game
yes uh that does certainly come up and i
think there's an implication i think a
lot of the marketing
that we are doing
seeks to
really sort of draw out what is unique
about new hampshire
i think there are other states certainly
that would fall into the same category
as being viewed as safe i think vermont
probably remain typically states that we
compete with for these very same
uh individuals and workforce and so on
so
it's it's not the strongest of
delineators but it is something that is
certainly i think recognized i hear a
lot of the same sort of thing um
and maybe it's a little bit implied in
some of the type of advertising that we
do but again we're trying to draw really
what's unique about new hampshire
because when it comes down to it you
know it's in new hampshire is it maine
it's in vermont
is it montana
what what really sort of gives us that
pitch
right thank
you questions
saying thank you for mentioning it
nice to see everyone
unfolding
tomorrow
see a lot of red white blue license
plates on sunday that'll be good
all right
okay
okay we're going to take a break until
one o'clock at one o'clock we're going
to have
rich lavers deputy commissioner of the
department of employment security and
brian gottlob
director of the economic and labor
market information bureau
they'll be discussing the labor market
and pandemic impact on unemployment
compensation and employment
so we'll see you at one o'clock
um
i'll try not to screw that up
all right you want to take your seats
okay we're going to be
hearing from richard lavers
rich lavers deputy commissioner of the
department of employment security
and brian gottlock
director of the economic and labor
market information bureau
discussing labor market and the pandemic
impact on unemployment and compensation
and employment
rich labors is currently the deputy
commissioner at the new hampshire
employment security
rich has held this position since being
originally appointed in 2013
he joined nhes in 2010
as an attorney bringing experience from
the
from work in both the private and public
sectors and brian gottlop
has been the director of new hampshire
economic and labor market information
bureau since 2019.
prior to that brian was the principal
and founder of polycon
research in dover for more than 20 and
that was for more than 25 years
brian has been actively working on
economic research projects
impacting every aspect of new hampshire
life and i can vouch for that because
many times
he's come before a ways and means
committee
so
rich you come you go on first
all right good afternoon everybody
just fix this
so
the only security i have right now for
being able to trust brian on advancing
the slides for me are that i have to
advance the slides for him
in a couple of minutes so i know that
he'll be good to me as i will be good to
him
so i'm going to get started i'm going to
talk a little bit about recapping our
experiences over the last few years
with the pandemic with what we've been
paying out who's who's been utilizing
the unemployment program i'm going to
talk a little bit about the experiences
of employers with their tax rates as
they fund our unemployment compensation
system as we all know and talk a little
bit about the trust fund where it is at
and what we are forecasting over the
next few years and then i'll hand it off
to brian to talk about trends in labor
force and what he sees happening
and all of the the tools that he
regularly looks at and reviews
and talk about
what he thinks will be happening with
the rest of this year
so we'll go to the the first slide
um so this you can see um what we've
paid out um in comparing what we paid
out during the pandemic uh calendar
years 20 and 21 just over 2 billion
dollars across all federal and state
unemployment programs
compare that to the prior 15 years
we where we exceeded that
in just that short period of time so
2021 paid out more benefits than we did
in the 15 years prior
now i've heard
from a lot of folks that have
attributed that
to the fact that there are a lot of
additional federal benefits being paid
out and we can see in the next slide
here that's certainly the case
most of what we paid out was in the form
of one of the federal programs that we
administered on behalf of the federal
government
we have an alphabet soup here of program
names but you can see in our top line
here the f-puc program which was the
program that paid additional benefits on
top of red gram so that was started off
as an additional six hundred dollars a
week and ended as an additional three
hundred dollars a week that was over a
billion dollars in benefits that were
paid out here in new hampshire just in
that program alone our red bar here is
the payments from our state unemployment
comp trust fund so that was about
350 million dollars that came out of the
fund directly financed by new hampshire
employers
pua was the federal companion program to
that where we paid just about 343
million and then these other two
programs both federal programs
that
make up the balance of that just over
two billion dollars paid
now when we look at the next slide we
can see that not only did we did new
hampshire receive a lot more
unemployment benefits during those two
years compared to our prior 15 but when
we look at the number of unique
individuals that relied upon the
unemployment system
during 20 and 21 we compare that against
2019 not really much of a comparison
against 2019 right
where we had nearly 176 000 individuals
that relied upon the unemployment
program during those two years almost a
quarter of our entire labor force you
compare that against 19 where we had
just over 14 000 people really not much
of a comparison there well let's then we
look back over to the left of this chart
and we see
during our peak years of the great
recession how does that compare i mean
just under a hundred thousand people
relied upon the unemployment program
during the great recession which was
about 13 of the labor force at that time
so you can see not only did we pay out a
lot more benefits but we had a lot more
individuals that were relying upon the
program
during our most recently completed two
years
when we look at where we are at now and
how that compares to some of our
milestone weeks
over the the pandemic period you can see
on the left hand side of this chart the
week prior
to the expanded unemployment occurring
prior to the state entering its state of
emergency prior to the federal
government passing the cares act march
of 20. we're at about 4 000 individuals
filing weekly claims for unemployment
benefits we quickly
ballooned
in the beginning of of may where we saw
over 116 nearly 117 000 people in one
single week
filing for unemployment benefits that
was our peak week during the pandemic
and you can see where we came down in
january of 21 and now where we find
ourselves in january of 22 back
not only below
pre-pandemic levels for the number of
claimants or number of individuals
relying upon the unemployment program in
any given week but we're actually about
30 to 35 percent below
where we were prior to the pandemic
i mean that will that's an important
point to remember when we get into some
later on slides and when brian starts to
discuss
things like quit rates and higher quit
rates right now none of that is really
translating over into higher
unemployment claims and brian will be
able to talk about what that means in
terms of the churn that we're seeing in
the labor force
on this slide despite being messy with a
lot of information which i apologize for
what we're trying to show here
with this slide is that
where we where we started in
2021 in the spring of 21 and we try to
mark some um what we consider to be some
very important milestones with policy
decisions that were made that we feel
have had a dramatic influence over the
utilization of the unemployment program
over that period of time so you can see
back in in april uh when uh work search
requirements were announced as uh to be
coming back um when uh the governor
announced that we would be ending
participation in the federal enhanced
and extended programs
as well as
the introduction of a return to work
bonus
so you can see what the the claim
behaviors have actually been
during that period
and as we move over to the right hand
side of the screen
you can see as we get to up to current
you'll see that we just recently hit our
20-year low
for the number of individuals filing for
unemployment during any given week
that was just prior to the holiday
period
and now we're just under 3 000
individuals
that are
filing each week
when you compare that to how new
hampshire stacks up against other
surrounding states in new england
and the country as a whole in terms of
how quickly we have recovered when we
utilize the number of individuals
utilizing the unemplo unemployment
program as a metric you can see
new hampshire being the red line in this
chart as it always is
in charts from the department
you see that we're at about two and a
half percent
of our peak in terms of the number of
individuals filing for unemployment
right now as compared to that peak week
that we saw back in may of 2020.
when you look at that compared to the
u.s as a whole with the black line here
you can see the u.s as a whole is about
nine percent of their peak week and the
new england states at about 11 and a
half percent of their peak week so you
can see while new hampshire has had a
dramatic reduction in individuals that
are utilizing the unemployment program
we have
seen the those numbers fall at a faster
rate compared to our neighboring states
and the country as a whole
now
when we
hear all about the the the extraordinary
amount of benefits that have been paid
the extraordinary number of individuals
that have utilized the program
um we then
want to talk about well what has
occurred with regard to our employers
who finance
our unemployment compensation system
here in the state either are for-profits
who pay on a quarterly basis or are
non-profits who pay back on a
reimbursement basis for benefits that
are paid out for benefits that are paid
from the regular state unemployment
program those federal programs are all
financed by the federal government when
we're not charged to our employers
what we are showing here with this state
with this slide is on the left you can
see where our average unemployment rate
for for-profit
tax-paying employers were peaked out
during the great recession you see
nearly 3.7 percent as an average tax
rate back in 2011 in that first quarter
now to put that into perspective a new
employer here in new hampshire they they
come in at a starting tax rate of 2.7
percent
they pay that 2.7 percent on the first
14 000 of annual earnings to each
employee
um so that 3.7
that that was a was a stayed at a
stubborn high number
for quite some time after peaking out in
the great recession you can see when we
move to the right of this chart with the
with the
red bar on the right hand side where we
peaked out during the pandemic at just
over 2.3 percent
and are coming down
at a much faster clip than we did during
the great recession we can't see it on
this slide we missed it by a few hours
but we actually
had our q3 average tax rate number for
2021 which actually fell
from the 1.85 you see in q2 where it
came down to 1.67
for q3 so continued decline in that
average tax rate for our for-profit
employers and and the reasons for this
um
it's not just it's not a coincidence
it's not just uh we got fortunate uh
that the tax rates during the pandemic
stayed lower than they did during the
great recession uh there were there were
several reasons for this one um and
something that um
gets uh somewhat um
overlooked
because the main focus of
the emergency orders originally issued
at the start
of the the pandemic in march of 2020
were really focused on expanding
eligibility for unemployment benefits
but one of the key provisions
and emergency order five from the
governor was a
changing the way benefits paid out from
the fund were treated in terms of how
they were charged
so starting in march of 20
through the end of the state of
emergency all benefits that were paid
out of the state trust fund so those
individuals that were eligible for
regular state unemployment
those benefits were direct charge to the
fund rather than being charged against a
for-profit employer's experience
and also our non-profits were not
required to reimburse the fund for those
dollars that were paid out
the the impact of that is that during
that time period our for-profit
employers they had the the positive
influence on their tax rates and their
experience of taxes that they were
paying into the system they didn't have
that negative experience from a from a
tax rate perspective of the benefits
being paid out being charged against
their experience so it had no it didn't
have a negative
effect on their rate or a positive rate
in that matter and driving it up so that
kept rates lower
we also had a 50 million dollar infusion
of cares act money that was deposited
into the trust fund helped to stabilize
the trust fund at the time that that
deposit was made our fund had fallen to
between 45 and 50 million million
dollars from the from where we started
at 300 million at the start of the
pandemic
and what we were able to do as a result
of that infusion of karzak money was we
were able to
it prevented us from implementing a
second
0.5 surcharge on employer tax rates and
it allowed us to remove the first .5
surcharge on employer tax rates earlier
than we had initially expected
now
the landscape with regard to surcharges
and
solvency controls
for employer tax rates that are set in
statute that landscape has changed since
then we no longer have
those surcharges as part of
the statutory solvency controls in 282a
that was a change
introduced by the governor and the
the trailer bill the legislature
kept that in
so those surcharges no longer exist
so going forward there aren't there is
not the possibility of those surcharges
being added to rates but in a
give-and-take
type of relationship where we were
removing those surcharges from the
statute
the
balance thresholds at which employers
received tax rate reductions those were
also changed in order to allow the fund
to grow
to a higher amount a more realistic
solvent amount
during times that employers would be
better able to afford it rather than
hitting them with surcharges during an
economic
downturn
so going forward there aren't
possibility of surcharges and unless
obviously that's changed and the
legislature were to change that
but we think that those provisions uh
those decisions that were made are
largely responsible for rates staying at
a at a lower peak during the pandemic as
compared to the recession a decade prior
and
finishing up here with with my portion
of the presentation i'll turn it over to
brian a couple of slides just on
where we are at in terms of our
unemployment compensation trust fund
and where we are forecasting that fund
to go
and also when we are forecasting those
fund balance reductions or those
discounts that apply to for-profit
employer tax rates when we are expecting
those to kick in
this first slide is just a a shot of the
current forecasting tool that we utilize
brian and his team have put a lot of
hard work into developing this and why
we want to show this to you so you can
understand that
with our current forecasting abilities
we are able to
move much more quickly with regard to
potential changes
in moving different levers
that have an influence over over trust
fund
revenues
and we point that out so that you know
that you have an understanding of that
and that we can um make
those types of forecasts uh based upon
different types of policy changes
legislative changes that you might be
looking at and this tool is available to
you
that we can utilize to assist in any way
with any of those types of changes that
you might be looking at going forward
and again the credit for that really
goes to brian and his team for having
developed that
to assist with
accurate forecasting and doing it in a
quick fashion
and being able to take in a lot of
variables
in order to do that
so our slide here shows you where we
feel the trust fund is going based upon
the
analysis of
our economic and labor market
information bureau
and you can see that we're forecasting
to end calendar year 22 at about
285 just under 286 million dollars again
right now today we're sitting at about
194 million dollars
we are forecast to end
at just under 320 million
and 2024
at
354 million now going to the next slide
and here we are you can see in our
center column labeled fbr that's the
forecasted fund balance reductions
we are forecasting that the
the first fund balance reduction the 0.5
reduction to employer tax rates
will kick in with the first quarter of
that is triggered by the fund
maintaining a balance of at least 250
million dollars in that prior quarter of
uh the fourth quarter of 22.
first quarter tends to be the most
expensive quarter for most employers so
that is an opportune time
to be having that first reduction hit
when we look at the additional
reductions in statute we still with the
the changes made as part of the trailer
bill that second reduction of a full
percent that kicks in when the fund
maintains a balance of 350 million
dollars for for a full quarter
we expect that that will be
hitting
could be as soon as the fourth quarter
of
2024 um
or it could be the first quarter of
2025.
you'll see in those
2024 balances quarter ending balances
for the third
for the second and third quarter
you see that we are right around that
350 million mark
so a few million dollars
here or there
could have a
an impact in terms of whether or not
the
one percent reduction is hit for that
fourth quarter or if it is delayed until
the first quarter of 25.
within our forecasting period right now
we're not up to the
level that the third and final fund
balance reduction of 1.5
would kick in that would kick in at
400 million with the statutory changes
that have been made
but this is where we're looking at going
out through
and with that
being said and talking about the
finishing up with the trust fund i'll
turn it over to brian and he'll talk a
little bit about where we are in labor
force trends and some of the tools that
he uses
to try to help with this forecasting
thank you rich
first of all thank you for the
invitation to see many familiar faces so
it's really a pleasure to be back
speaking before you again in a different
role well not quite a different role i
think i did this last year
at a at a similar time um this is just
the first chart is just kind of an
overview of some of the things that i'd
like to talk about or kind of an overall
assessment
i'll get into the weeds on some of these
charts and i hate to lose anybody so
when i do lose you as i inevitably do
here are some of the things that i'd
like you to think about or take away
from my presentation
one the labor market is in good shape
we've got a higher number of job
openings than we had prior to the
pandemic we have a higher percentage of
jobs job openings
than
the nation overall
but we also have higher quit rates
we have more people leaving jobs
often to take other jobs
and that's helping to boost the number
of job openings
job growth has accelerated in new
hampshire in the second half of 2021
we
also believe that the bureau of labor
statistics who does a monthly estimate
of the number of jobs in new hampshire
has been under counting
those jobs and that will be corrected a
little bit later this year next month
when we do benchmarking but we still
look good in in terms of our job growth
we think we'll get back to pre-pandemic
levels of employment by the end of 2022
also think that the u.s economy will get
back all of the jobs that it lost during
the pandemic it'll take almost another
year or so before we get back to our
pre-pandemic trend level of growth we'll
recover jobs that we had at uh beginning
of 2020 but that will kind of discount
all the jobs that we might have created
in 21 and 22.
the bad news is the omicron variant of
the coronavirus is clearly having a
negative impact on labor issues
nationally and in new hampshire it's
resulted in more people not being in
work temporarily at least
than
than we had expected and as high as
we've seen throughout the pandemic
our labor force in new hampshire also
remains lower than it was prior to the
pandemic
and i'll talk a fair amount about that
it tends to be in a few
demographic categories that are most
likely to have seen a shrinkage in in
their labor force
and it's going to be unlikely that we
get back to that pre-pandemic level any
time soon for a couple of reasons that
i'll talk about
and it that makes it really critical
that we get everybody who can be in the
labor force into the labor force and as
importantly not only that but
we had labor shortage prior to the
pandemic the pandemic has exacerbated
those labor shortages
so people who are in the labor force
have to be put to their highest and best
use they have to be matched to the jobs
that are in demand
and they have to work to their full
potential if the new hampshire economy
is going to be operating at its full
potential
lastly
ending this on a positive note
one of the issues that has been most
optimistic to me over the past year is
the fact that the net in migration into
new hampshire from other states more
people moving into the state than moving
out of the state
has just taken off
this past year we were back to 1980
early 1990 levels of net in migration
about twice what i had forecast
about this time last year
and that has real positive ramifications
for both our labor force
and our demographic challenges that we
face next slide
so this is just a quick chart showing um
the monthly job postings
in the state and as you see at the very
end here we've had some ups and downs
but overall the trend is more job
openings than we saw
prior to the pandemic and that's not an
epiphany to you folks you can't drive
along any
road that has businesses on it and not
see help wanted signs so there's plenty
of opportunities out there the fact that
we have very low unemployment rates and
low unemployment claims
is a testament to this we don't if
people want to work we have jobs for
them
the one of the reasons why we have so
many job openings and i mentioned is the
fact that we have
very high quit rates and this is a
three-month moving average i will tell
you that in the most recent month
because there's some variability so i
like to use a three month moving average
new hampshire had i think about the
fifth highest quit rate of any
state in the nation so as you see again
new hampshire always the red line
for comparison massachusetts and the
gray line is the u.s you see how rapidly
the quit rates in new hampshire
accelerated and why would that be well
it's in large part well there's a couple
of reasons one we have a very high
percentage
of employment in industries that have
among the highest quit rates
that tends to be
hospitality industries where people
change jobs a lot a lot for a lot of
individuals
it's their first job they move on to
another job
the quit rates in that industry have
accelerated they have the highest quit
rates of any industry retail another
industry that has a lot very high quit
rates also increased we have a high
percentage of retail employment in
addition we're seeing some industries
that traditionally have relatively low
cri quit rates
we're seeing much higher quit rates
health care being among the most
prominent
where
traditionally health care has had a
below average quit rate now they're
about at the average but the percentage
increase is about 50 percent so a 50
percent increase in the quit rates in
healthcare and it makes sense those
industries are industries that one
healthcare burnout hospitality
you know it was very difficult during
the pandemic to have face-to-face
contact you were asked to do a lot you
were asked to
enforced social distancing
all kinds people were not particularly
nice during the pandemic many of them so
i i you could see why the the quit rates
would rise next year
this is just a chart that depicts where
we came from in terms of employment in
new hampshire and where we are now
the blue line is where employment total
employment in the state was heading
prior to the pandemic you see just at
the very end a little dip that was one
month or two months so i wasn't
particularly worried about that although
we were expecting that growth was going
to slow a little bit even prior to the
pandemic you know we were running into
real significant labor shortages prior
to the pandemic
pandemic hits and that's the red line we
lose a hundred and twenty thousand jobs
hundred twenty thousand either
temporarily
most of them temporarily some of them
permanently we bounce back very quickly
at least a percentage-wise and then we
saw kind of some variability fits and
starts you know we it looked good in the
summer
my second wave hits later in the year we
see again
you know slow down in job growth
but we're back on the right path and
again
my view is and i'm i'm
100 confident that the numbers here will
actually be higher when we get the
benchmark revisions we're actually
adding more jobs so we're my belief is
we're about
80 percent back or 85 percent back um to
the pre pandemic levels of employment
and we should finish that off um to 400
percent by the end of the year
next slide
and this is a very nerdy chart it is
also my favorite metric for assessing
where
the labor market is
a lot of people look at
the unemployment rate which is a really
fine metric
and other people look at the labor force
participation rate and say that's their
preferred
metric we know that labor force
participation has been down
and we know that the unemployment rate
is back to where it was prior to the
pandemic but does that mean
that we're back to full employment does
that mean that our economy
you know every everybody's working
at the same rates they were before no
i take a look at the labor
the employment the population ratio
among the group of individuals that have
the highest labor force participation
rate individuals 25
to 54. those are people who participate
in the labor force at the highest rates
of any anyone about 90 percent of people
in those age groups are
are working or are in the labor force
so anytime new hampshire is at about 85
percent that means we're basically at
full employment
and you can see times when we've dipped
below that
recession
in the early 2000s and this is a
12-month moving average so
they give you some perspective it's not
a a actual monthly average 12-month
moving average during the great
recession
it dipped well below
so
below that 85 and now
here and also dip very the thing that i
find really interesting about this chart
is that
we didn't dip even though we know we had
a 16 unemployment rate at one point
our employment to population ratio among
this age group 25 to 54 prime working
age years
really didn't
change much from a time period when we
had six or seven percent unemployment
rate during the great recession why
would that be
well
it explains who was
who
wasn't working most during
the pandemic
young people in particular because why
they're employed a lot in hospitality in
recreation and retail those were the
jobs that disappeared fastest
so those people are counted in this
in this age group so that really
explains it but it still says we're
about
1.4 percent below what i consider in new
hampshire to be a full employment
economy so we've still got a ways to go
long explanation i i love the start
i have to tell you the unemployment rate
is my least favorite economic indicator
we're at 2.6 percent now
we were at 2.6 before the pandemic we do
not have the same economy that we had
prior to the pandemic
next chart please
again
just to kind of put into perspective
where we are relative to other states i
tend to focus most of my attention on
the private sector employment because
that gives me a better idea of what's
happening in in in the economy as
opposed to what's happening in
government
and this just shows
where every state is in terms of their
pre-pandemic
level of employment so basically
february of 2020 and how far below they
are that level of employment compared to
every other state
new hampshire's in the middle so you say
okay that's
mediocre but in fact
if you look at all the states that have
gained back more of the jobs none of
them are in the northeast
the northeast was the hardest hit region
in terms of layoffs in terms of
restrictions on economic activity
so we wouldn't expect we would expect
that we would have those states would
have further to recover
new hampshire among all the northeastern
states and certainly among all the new
england states has recovered more of its
private sector jobs than any other state
so we do have something to be proud of
i focus
one of the things that the pandemic has
done
is it has highlighted
the necessity to have more real-time
indicators of economic activity and
government
my agency included bureau of labor
statistics
doesn't produce
really timely data we get it on a
monthly basis and then it's a six week
lag or sometimes it's a quarter lag
so people have looked a lot at private
sector sources of data this is a metric
that i really like because it's done on
a daily basis and it's a cnn
moody's analytics
back to normal index and basically what
it looks at is it says compared to what
every
each individual state their how their
economy was performing prior to the
pandemic where are they at right now
and it has about 20 national indicators
and six or seven from every individual
state to do that so it doesn't compare
state to state it just compares new
hampshire to itself prior to the
pandemic and what you see here
is the red line again new hampshire
we bottomed pretty low
we were operating at only 60 percent
of our economic activity prior to the
pandemic early in the pandemic we bounce
back quicker than the nation we bounced
back quicker than most states
massachusetts used here because we like
to compare ourselves so much to
massachusetts
but then
as
weather changed as people moved inside
as virus took
hold and we had a second wave
the economy took a hit people were less
willing to engage in their normal
economic activities we dropped down we
improved again
and what happened
in
late summer early fall of this year the
delta wave and the delta wave took
uh had an impact a negative impact on
economic activity
most recently
we had we're still we got to 99 of our
of our pre-pandemic level of economic
activity most recently you see the drop
there and that's related to the omicron
variant
which is clearly having an impact on
economic activity next slide
i this slide is a little bit out of
order
but one of the reasons why i think we
there's many reasons why i think we are
adding more jobs than has
been indicated by the bureau of labor's
physicians one of them is this
we're adding new businesses new business
formations this is a chart that shows
the number
of new business formations in a subgroup
of businesses so every business when it
forms applies for an employer
identification number with the internal
revenue service and that
information is readily available
this looks at the number of employer
identification numbers filed in new
hampshire for a subgroup of businesses
that
we call high propensity or higher
they're businesses that
when they they're not sole proprietors
they're businesses that have employees
they're manufacturers
you know it could be
restaurants
it's all industries and all businesses
that generally have very few
single and single employee businesses
proprietors but have employees
that number dropped dramatically during
the pandemic we expected that about we
expected it to bounce back bounce back
people who delayed
those filings but since then it has
remained elevated has and has been
picking up
so we've got a lot of entrepreneurial
activity
having looked at this kind of data for
20 years i can tell you any time we see
high levels of entrepreneurial activity
in new hampshire
employment numbers get revised upward
these are companies
they start they form over they apply for
a number they eventually
eventually employ people those companies
do not get into the regular
sample the survey that the bureau of
labor statistic does for probably close
to a year
so all of these new activity isn't
showing up in the employment numbers
so i
they do eventually
and i think a lot of this will be
corrected in our benchmark maybe not all
of it but it's a clear indication to me
that that we'll see higher employment
numbers another one that i didn't put
here which would be redundant is our own
administrative records
um we have looking at the
second quarter of 2021 to the second
quarter of 2020 we had 8 percent more
number of businesses private businesses
that we're paying into our unemployment
insurance fund
so we know that there's a lot of
entrepreneurial activity we know that
there's a lot of businesses that most
likely aren't showing up in those
employment estimates next slide
i mentioned um
the the impacts that the that the
omicron variant has had um i can't
emphasize this enough and that you know
it's not a political statement but
you know getting that under control will
have
real significant positive economic
benefits
what's happening most recently this is a
a survey that is done by the census
bureau it's been done since the early
part of the pandemic
and it asked individuals
throughout the country and in individual
states
um why they aren't if they're not
working why they're not working
and there is a particular question
that's that says that gives them the
choice of i was carrying caring for
someone or i was sick myself with the
coronavirus
this is the number of people who say
they're not working
because of that reason
and you see back early
in the in the pandemic you'd say well
how come those numbers weren't higher
well it's because so many businesses
were shut down that was the reason that
people weren't working
businesses opened up
we had a second wave as
winter of last year more people were
sick more people were caring for
individuals who were sick in their
families
and we had
somewhere over six million people
indicating that they were either sick or
they were taking care of someone
we get down again weather improves
looking really good the delta wave hits
and that number peaks up and then you
can look at the very end the omicron
variant
just how many people over the last month
have indicated that they're not working
because they're either sick or taken
care of
those numbers by the way
that
took off
just before the december
the
employment estimates are done
on a survey during one week of every
month and it's the week that contains
the 12th of the month
the december employment report that was
reported early in january didn't really
capture this
the report for january that's going to
come out next friday
will reflect about this time period here
very real possibility and i don't want
to go out on a limb but it's a very real
possibility that the nation will report
no net job growth
for january largely because of that i
could be wrong but i bet the number is
going to be very low now new hampshire
produces these the survey is also done
for new hampshire tends to be a very
small sample so it bounces around so i
didn't want to put it on here but i will
tell you that the magnitude of increase
is similar even if it's not the exact
number
next slide
just another indication of what we're
dealing with
in terms of
the the coronavirus and how i look at
what impacts is having this is a measure
of
trips to workplaces google google tracks
all of us i say this all the time it
doesn't track me because i never put my
location on my i never have the location
feature of my phone on but it tracks and
it categorizes
where people are going based on you know
the their knowledge of the location of
where people wind up so workplaces
retail
recreation this looks at changes in
trips to workplaces
since the pandemic and it measures
trips to workplaces as a percentage of
what they were prior to the pandemic so
again
the far left early in the pandemic trips
to workplaces were down 50 percent
workplaces were closed people were
working from home etc we improved we got
pretty consistently 20
below because people were still working
from home each big dip there is
associated with a holiday so people
obviously weren't going to work couple
things about this chart that i think are
important one new hampshire overall
didn't see as big a decline in trips to
workplaces as the nation overall
the second most important thing
is that
as we get more toward the end here and
again the period when the
omkron virus was starting to hit
the distance or the gap between new
hampshire's trips to workplaces that
change in the u.s declines so we were
looking more like the u.s
and when you get down to the very end
we're basically
seeing the same kind of cutbacks and
trips to workplaces as the u.s the other
thing last thing that's really important
about this
i mentioned that every
holiday is associated with a decline in
trips to workplaces
well if you look at christmas new year
holiday of 2021
the decline in trips to the workplaces
is actually lower
than it was
in 2020. what does that say
that's the impact
the mo of the most recent variant of the
coronavirus it's having that kind of
impact
again it's temporary
and all indications are that it's
improving but it is having a significant
impact next year
again i don't want to belabor the point
same this is another private sector
metric that i look at it's restaurant
reservations seeded restaurant
reservations every state company open
table takes reservations for a select
group of restaurants it compares it to
the same
day
in 2019 and how restaurant reservations
compare
new hampshire again
looked better and we know this you know
this because of what happened with
rooms and meals taxes we did pretty well
so
we were
in much of the during much of the
pandemic pretty close or above
significantly above where we were in
again
until very recently
we get down to the time period this is
actually
i think ended that january 8th i think
that data ends
we see new hampshire reservation
restaurant reservations actually
declined on a percentage basis more than
the us
again that's the impact so
we're seeing a pretty significant
negative impact
in terms of labor labor availability in
terms of people's willingness to engage
in normal economic activities driving to
work going to work because of illness
because they're taking care of somebody
because their offices
are going back to remote work how many
i know
a number of individuals who had been
working
from their offices had gone back to work
and now are back to working remotely
we're seeing a lot of that
but again this is temporary but it gives
an idea of how significant the impact
has been
um talk about labor force
starting to run late here this is what's
happened to the new hampshire labor
force i said we may not get back to
our
level of labor force that we saw
pre-pandemic
some demographic groups have cut back
their participation much more than
others
chief among them
workers
older workers 60 and above
why would that be well some is related
to health
concern
but 60 to 64 is the one that is from my
perspective really significant one we've
got a lot of individuals in that
that age group
and it has they've seen the biggest
decline in their labor force petition
why would that be well some of it may be
health
related concerns during the pandemic but
the other aspect of it is if you think
back what's happened to people's
retirement savings if they have them and
a lot of people do in this state stock
market has gone up dramatically housing
values have gone up dramatically and a
lot people have felt more comfortable
with their possibility of stepping out
of the labor force and retiring so we've
seen that
nationally the percentage of individuals
who are eligible for social security who
actually filed
was much higher last year than it had
ever been about two million more people
filed for social security last year who
were eligible then would be expected
if they filed at the same rate that they
had in prior years i don't have that
data for new hampshire
i'm sure it's the same
in new hampshire the other group
that's interesting is younger folks
and that's the real concern the
individuals at the upper end some of
them will come back in the labor force
perhaps
but we can't expect them to come back
in
significant numbers or back to the level
which is really important because the
labor force people have been working
longer and we've been counting on that
they're working longer why because we
have fewer jobs that require physical
strength and ability more of our jobs we
do like me sitting at a computer so you
didn't have to have it it's one thing to
be at a computer working when you're 70
years old is another thing to try and be
on a roof fixing a roof you know so
we were counting on that it looks like
it's not going to bounce back the other
group is the young younger folks
particularly 25 to 29
all young folks
has have cut back 25 to 29 particularly
young males
why would that be well
a lot of those individuals
were employed in industries that you
know there were layoffs they received
significant
income support
we had stimulus payments that
added a couple few thousand dollars to
everybody's account if you're 25 i think
back to when i was 25 years old
if i was getting that money i would
might take an extra few months off um
before i have eventually those people
will come back they can't remain out of
the workforce for 40 years we also had a
moratorium and still do on student loans
again took some of the pressure off
individuals from working so there was
more of incentive the other group that i
want to just highlight
35 to 39 and that's a little different i
said 25 to 29 was young men
tend to be a higher percentage of young
men
35 to 39 tends to be more women and show
the next chart here and a lot of that
has to do with child care issues
um
you know this is a chart that just shows
what's happened to the child care
industry and just a segment of the child
care industry because a lot of child
care is
family businesses that don't
necessarily have employees formal
employees so this just looks at the
segment of the
industry that has
employees that reports to our
unemployment into our employment
unemployment insurance fund you see the
number it's really took a toll the
pandemic has really taken a toll hard to
get workers
that's created significant problems for
women again 35 to 39 is uh and even into
the later 20s are most likely to be
the parents of children's ages six and
under which have the most dramatic child
care needs
so until and this is a vexing problem so
until that gets solved we're going to
struggle i think uh with
getting that segment of the workforce
back excellent
just putting some numbers on it
applying the same level of labor force
participation each of these demographic
groups that was present in 2019 again
prior to the pandemic to the current
number of individuals
in those demographic groups in new
hampshire
this is how many more or fewer people we
would have in the labor force in each of
these demographic groups
so all told we'd have about 22 000 more
people in the labor force if we had 2019
labor force participation rate
this is
the key to our recovery is really
getting those individuals back into the
labor force
i did want to i do want to finish up
with a couple of the last two with some
positive notes i mentioned the in
migration the net in migration this is
just the chart goes back to 2001 i could
go back to the 80s where you'd see
regular 15 to 20 000 net
in migration we saw a period of time
where
you as policy makers and everybody in
the state was very concerned that we
were losing more people than we were
gaining and there were some real reasons
for that the
great recession
the kind of individuals that typically
moved into the state tended to be
families two-way journey married couple
families
college educated
they were moving here they probably
owned a house somewhere else ages 30 to
44 they probably owned a house it would
have been difficult for them to sell a
lot of people underwater would want to
buy that was also difficult during that
time so we saw some net outfitters it
picked up again
you know as the economy got back to full
employment
as housing market sees
but the most recent and this is 2020 but
it's really 2020 to july of 2021. i had
forecast a little over 6 000 individuals
on net would move in that is a pretty
significant increase from the prior
years and it turns out census bureau
reports that we actually added 13 500.
why
there was a definite
desire for less density
as the pandemic hit we saw big
exodus from cities and metropolitan
areas boston metro area
hartford new york city
new hampshire is a real
magnet for that was a real magnet for
that and i track
views of homes for sale
new hampshire was two to three times the
national average maine as well this is
the chart that shows how we
compare to other states it's
that number of individuals on net who
moved into the state compared to moved
out as a percentage of our 2020
employment so
all of northern new england benefited
from that desire for less density and
the ability to remote work remotely so
new hampshire is going to get a real
good demographic benefit from this
because i think even if it's not as
strong
it will still play out
moving forward as remote work
opportunities increase
the key question is we're going to get a
great we're going to get great
demographic benefits
key question is
can we keep this rolling and can we keep
it rolling
because we don't have a lot of places
for people
to live
who want to move here we're seeing that
dealing with that in spades right now
we have constraints on housing there's
not we know that vacancy rates rental
vacancy rates are at historic lows
there's not a lot being built that's
going to be a real constraint i think we
have a great opportunity to address our
demographics
by this movement into the state which is
how we traditionally have dealt with it
we're not going to increase our birth
rates that's not going to happen
so i think we've got to get um and solve
some of these housing issues in order
for us to to see the real benefits last
slide
this is my forecast of job growth um 3.8
i think will wind up eventually in when
all is said and done
or very close to it i think we're at
about right now 3.4
given what bls thinks and i believe is
an underestimate 2022 will be a little
bit slower by 2023 we'll start really
running into even more severe labor
constraints but overall that is in that
implies that we'll get back to our full
our pre-planademic levels of employment
by the end of this year and it will take
about another year before we get back to
our pre-pandemic trend growth that we
would have expected had the pandemic not
occurred and with that i will stop and
thank you
for your indulgence in that long
presentation
questions
reps in a while
thank you mr chairman
my online messages keep telling me that
biden's going to take away my ira we're
going to have an economy collapse in
2023 or 2024 the new people that are
forecasting are all rosy
uh
i don't know what to believe
what
you probably have more figures than he
does but
yeah
well
i'm not sure
where that information came from uh look
the you know the economy right now is in
much better shape than i think is
commonly recognized
we know that the labor market is strong
we know that we just saw a gdp growth
that was um you know
for the quarter over almost seven
percent for the year was 5.7 percent a
little bit less i think at this time
last year i was saying i thought it
would be close to seven percent but we
had two variants of of the coronavirus
that took a lot off um
you know and we do have some real
challenges um but i think the majority
of economic forecasters believe that
overall the economy's in
in good shape people household incomes
are strong income growth has been good
the big issues that we face
are on the supply side and they're on
the supply side again largely because of
a pandemic they have
really disrupted the supply chains
both in the us but particularly in asia
and and southeast asia where we rely on
a lot of products
until those things
get resolved we're going to be
constrained on on supply demand is there
people have money they want to spend and
when they want to spend and supply
doesn't keep up what happens
prices go up
so that's a real danger my original
forecast i had thought energy prices
will come down this first half of this
year
that isn't looking as as likely there's
some world events that are causing some
problems there and i thought the second
half of the year we would see supply
chain issues start to get resolved in
combination that would result in prices
being significantly look
30 percent of the rise in prices over
the last year is related to automobiles
to automobiles the cost of automobiles
used car prices wholesale prices are up
56 percent over the year
so
that won't last
supply chain issues are taking longer
than i had anticipated but
you know those are very different
problems they're problems that we can
see the end of the end of a pandemic end
of
supply chain issues so i don't see a
cataclysmic or apocalyptic kind of
economic outlook
okay way over
there hello thank you thanks for the
great presentation i have some labor
force participation questions for you
lots of my constituent business owners
are always wondering where the people
went
and particularly the numbers on the 25
to 29 year olds the 4606 that left the
workforce where you said mostly were men
do you know what
industries they left from do you have
information on that oh yeah
what we do
we do to a degree yes
and again individuals
in that
age group tend to dominate in a few
industries they tend to you know it's a
lot of people early in their careers
they tend to work
and i'm this is such a a gross
generalization but more
young people work in hospitality
in retail in recreation industries so
those industries have been especially
hard hit by people leaving those
workforces hospitality industry in
particular you know if you look at the
the and health care is another one
though health care health care is a
little different health care
certain occupations in health care not
physicians not actual providers but
support occupations tend to have a
younger demographic they also tend to
have a female demographic 80 percent of
people who work in health care are
female
so the younger demographic is a lot is
more represented in the industries that
have been hardest or originally were
hardest hit retail hospitality
recreation
they were laid off they received
significant income support
the jobs didn't look all that attractive
for a while
and again without
many of them without family
responsibilities
student loans may be
you know as they have been delayed or a
moratorium on repayments made it a
little bit easier for people to step
back
step out but i didn't show you is a
trend of that and what you see is
we are off the trough we're off the
bottom
we saw the worst of the of the
lack of participation earlier in the
year
and it has been inching up if i showed
you that same
chart a month or two months ago you
would have seen not 4 700 you would have
seen like 5300
individuals not in the labor force so it
is getting better and it will get better
thank you
further questions
saying
hey
your presentations
excellent
i really appreciate it
thank you
thank you guys
you